foreign
and again I say good morning everyone
it's one of the hardest things of the
job of testifying is Turn on
it gives you a clue you get a little red
light so we will be kind and gracious
because we haven't mastered it either
foreign
my name is Richard head I'm the
government Affairs coordinator for the
judicial branch I'm joined today by
judge Ashley who is the Deputy
Administrator of the circuit court and
judge Garner who also sits in the
Circuit Court
just very briefly I'm going to have
everyone introduce themselves to you
I'll take 30 seconds because you really
don't want to hear from me today you're
going to see me the most over the course
of this session but for today when we
turn it over to the judges judge Ashley
will give a sort of overview of the
circuit court and judge Garner will
really focus on Family Division but
first we're just going to introduce
introductions and I'll address you for
good morning folks my name is Susan
Ashley and I'm the deputy administrative
judge for the circuit court judge king
was not able to be here today he's our
administrative judge so you likely are
more familiar with him I have the
opportunity as Deputy administrative
judge to do some of this administrative
type work but also I do still get to sit
in court as a presiding judge down in
usually Rochester sometimes I sub in
elsewhere but that's really where I I
hail from and so it's good to see all of
you today and I'll talk with you very
briefly after Richard does
morning my name is Michael Garner I'm a
circuit court judge
um and I sit in Laconia virtually
exclusively in the fourth circuit court
and I'll be talking mostly about Family
Division but as a circuit court judge I
hear all sorts of cases that come before
us and I'll be happy to answer whatever
questions any of you may have as I go
along thanks
and on that point we do encourage anyone
who has any questions you have two
judges who are here to answer any and
all questions that you may have just
very brief excuse me just just a
reminder to the folks here because we
have a lot of brand new reps uh you may
ask questions but I'm the gatekeeper so
put your hand up and because people
sometimes down the Far Corners are just
a bit out of my sight line it is
appropriate for people to to do that so
I can see a hand that is up yes fair
point Thank you Mr chairman
um and I apologize I won't be able to
see to the right that well
um
so very briefly you know there are two
trial courts in in the state of New
Hampshire we have the Superior Court
we're not going to focus on Superior
Court today
um but we also have the Circuit Court
Circuit Court
um in I think it was 2012. uh
Consolidated what used to be family
court probate court and District Court
it made them divisions of the circuit
court so we now have the circuit court
so we no longer have a family court we
have family division of the circuit
court and the judges in Circuit Court
can sit in any of the divisions and in
any particular day maybe sitting in all
of the divisions the the cases are all
um coming before them there tends to be
a a schedule within the course of a week
as to the type of cases so there may be
a day where you're going to hear
criminal cases there may be a day where
you're more likely to have the family
Docket in front of you
um but the Circuit Court judges can be
sitting in any of the divisions and with
that I'm just going to talk turn it over
to judge Ashley have her talk about
Circuit Court those divisions really
what it would have uh what it contains
uh thank you
thank you Richard so
um as Richard indicated under Circuit
Court there are the three divisions and
so you'll still see and hear a lot of
folks say I got to go down to District
Court right so District Court of course
pre-circuit Court there were Standalone
buildings that was the Local District
Court building when Family Division was
developed Family Division by and large
there are exceptions shared space in the
district court building so there was the
district Division and the Family
Division together then when Circuit
Court came along and pulled in a probate
as well then we have the three divisions
and those courts are scattered
throughout the state as Richard said our
judges do sit on all of these case types
or can be assigned to sit on all of
these case types and often are doing
that within the course of one day
probate of course is our smallest case
numbers but have some significant cases
particularly our trust cases but they
have the trusts in States guardianship
over in facetated individuals Equity
matters those types of cases then we
have our district division which is
probably most familiar to a lot of folks
because it has a small level criminal
cases also our small claims cases in in
civil cases of a certain lower Financial
value we do landlord-tenant cases in our
district division as well so those are
the primary matters that we're handling
in the district division is very busy
and it's a lot of folks coming in and
out of the courthouse for those matters
then we have Family Division and
obviously this committee is going to be
focused by and large on family cases
some folks automatically go to divorce
parenting which is what judge Garner is
going to likely spend a lot of time
talking with you about today but family
division is not just divorces in child
support and parenting cases there is the
large spectrum of all things family that
are in Family Division so that includes
our juvenile case abuse which includes
abuse and neglect cases delinquency
matters
Chin's cases children in need of
services those are all what we often
refer to as our juvenile cases there are
cases that come off of those sometimes
like termination of parental rights
we have our adoption cases also in
Family Division so those are all Family
Division case types we also handle
guardianship over minors so we have many
guardianship over minor cases and then
we have our domestic violence petitions
again those are the Civil petitions not
criminal charges that relate to domestic
violence those would be in District
division but our standard domestic
violence petition one person asking for
a protective order against another
person those are also handled in Family
Division so all of those things come to
us on a daily basis there are
emergencies involved in almost every one
of those Family Division case types and
so we need to be prepared to respond to
those on a daily basis in high high
volume but of course we also handle
divorce parenting child support and so
we're going to turn I'm going to turn it
over to judge Garner today to address
you on those matters but I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
on any of those divisions or anything in
particular in Family Division itself
thank you
just to put the the the
little context or scope in terms of the
numbers when we're talking
um Circuit Court you have about 125 new
125 000 new cases every year
um of those about 64 65 000 are criminal
um in the just domestic uh you have
about ten thousand
um and domestic violence around 4 500.
so just to put a little scope and
context in terms of of what is sort of
flowing through that court system thank
you
morning again thank you thank you for
I ordinarily sit in the Laconia Circuit
Court that's the fourth circuit court
and I'm there as a full-time judge I'm
the presiding judge there
um I would like to invite questions as
we go along the time available this
morning really won't give me an adequate
opportunity to touch on every facet of
the Circuit Court even every facet of
the Family Division but I think it's
more important for me to be a resource
to answer questions that you may have so
that so that you can have more of an
informed sense of what we do in the
court so feel free to ask
if you forget to ask a question and it
occurs to you later on
um have someone let Richard know and
send him an email and I'll be happy to
try to respond the only limitations on
answering questions are that
um please don't ask me about a case
that's pending somewhere whether you use
the name or not and I'll be grateful if
you don't ask me to weigh in on
particular proposed bills that are going
to be in front of your committee our
judicial branch has a way of addressing
those but that wouldn't be up that
decision wouldn't be up to somebody like
me and so I'm just going to defer to
them for that
I'm as a circuit court judge I'm
cross-trained in all three of the
divisions family district and probate
we have four courtrooms in Laconia and
there are three other judges who sit
there part-time
each of them with one exception the one
who does just probate each of them does
all of the things that any of us do
I also have a Judicial referee that we
work with that's a retired judge who's
over 70 who
sits part-time in Laconia doing
primarily juvenile cases but can do some
other cases as well and I have a child
support referee one of only two or three
in the state who does exclusively child
support
and also sits there part-time we share
him with Manchester a couple of days a
week
let me just supplement Richard's
description of the numbers involved by
letting you know the new case filings
that we had in the Laconia Family
Division last year based on my um
my inexpert review of the docket numbers
we had domestic relations cases about
385 new filings last year and by
Domestic Relations I mean divorce
parenting and those cases that are
exclusively child support typically
brought by the division
we had roughly half that number of cases
that are brought forward and these are
cases where there had been in the past a
final order
and the parties for whatever reason are
bringing the case forward to modify that
vital order in some way so we had
typically about half of the new filings
in addition to those are brought forward
cases in domestic violence cases we had
about 254 domestic violence petitions
filed last year in juvenile cases as
judge Ashley mentioned these are abuse
and neglect cases chins delinquency tpr
adoption cases we had 180 of those in
minor guardianship cases we had 85. and
so totaling that up we're looking at a
rough number of about a thousand cases
and Laconia Family Division filed last
year and I think that's basically an
accurate number in terms of the number
of active cases we have at any point in
time probably a thousand it goes up or
down obviously but that's the rough
number
in Family Division because I'm the
presiding judge and I'm there full-time
I'm responsible for something like 55 or
60 percent of those cases and that's
just how it falls out the part-time
judges come in and they get assigned
cases
and manage their dockets which are
similar to my dockets
I have three basic duties in what I do
my first Duty as a judge is to conduct
hearings to hear cases and to generate
orders from those hearings
I think you may have a copy of
um recent doctors do they have those
all right
you're going to get a copy of three days
of recent dockets I think that's Monday
through Wednesday of last week
that'll give you a sense of what we do
on a daily basis two one of those days
is a full day final hearing two of them
were typical list days with a variety of
different cases all within Family
Division
the second thing that I do as a
presiding judge is to field emergency
motions that get filed every day and
these would typically be in domestic
violence cases
for example if if the litigant gets an
emergency protective order from the
police the night before then that
litigant can come to court the next day
the emergency order stays in place until
4 pm and they can come to court and file
a domestic violence petition
there are also emergency motions that
are filed in parenting or divorce cases
really in any of the cases possibly but
those are the cases that come up most
often
and the presiding judge's job is to
review those filings when they're made
to determine whether there needs to be a
hearing immediately that day on on that
motion
to confirm that when it's required
there's been notice to the other side
and they have some opportunity to come
in and file an objection or a response
and to issue an order by the end of the
work day about those motions we never
know from day to day how many of those
motions they're going to be typically
Mondays are busy and typically Friday
afternoons are busy beyond that there's
always a certain number
um and so part of my job is to field
those motions and take the appropriate
steps to issue orders if necessary
the last part of my job that's sort of a
core function is to sign documents that
the clerk's office has put together that
are typically motions that are filed by
one side and then objections or
responses filed by the other side
there's the rule is 10 days to file an
objection or a response so the clerk
will get a motion they'll wait to 10
days and if an objection or response
comes in then those are put into the
file and the file is left for me to
review and sign those
and typically that's a significant part
of my work week I am lucky enough to
have two referees at the court where I
work a Judicial referee and a child
support referee
and each of their orders must be counter
signed by a judge who reviews the order
to determine whether they've applied the
correct legal standards so that sort of
adds to my pile of motions at any given
moment that I have to look at and sign
and um
aside from motions that are called
expedited motions I get to those motions
as I can
so those are my three core functions as
a judge as a circuit court judge I also
like all of my colleagues I'm available
to take emergency uh
emergencies that come up and that are
that need a Judicial order that happen
after hours so typically those who are
domestic violence emergency orders where
the police call up and say we'd like to
get an emergency protective order for
this person which good till the next day
if it's granted and sometimes those are
motions that are brought before me with
by dcyf who needs an emergency placement
for a child who may be removed from the
parents care for that for that moment
where all all of us are typically always
on call for those sorts of things
let me give you a sense of what my
typical day is like if that's helpful
for you
the court is open at eight o'clock in
the morning and we stay open until four
typically my hearing start at 8 30. and
so the time that I have to spend between
when I get to court and that first 8 30
hearing is typically spent looking at
the signing cart for emotions that may
be necessary for the clerk to have and
get to work on earlier in the day
looking at my files I'll pick up a stack
of files from the clerk's office and
take them upstairs to Chambers and I
begin to look at them
in the order in which they're going to
be heard so that I can reacquaint myself
with files that I have a certain level
of knowledge about and so I can learn
about files that I've never seen before
and I'll typically look at whatever the
current pleading is if it's emotions
hearing I'll look at the motion the
objection I'll try to get some sense of
the background and because I typically
do most of my own orders I'll create a
caption on my laptop that will allow me
later on to create an order once I've
done that hearing
I'll also check because the Belknap
County House of Corrections will is
available to us for video arraignments
at 10 o'clock every morning I'll check
to see if anyone's in custody and needs
to be arraigned typically the judge is
doing criminal docket will do that
arraignment at 10 o'clock in the morning
but sometimes we I don't have another
judge there and so it'll be up to me to
find a space within my family division
docket to go downstairs and do that
arraignment
our hearings are typically scheduled for
30 minutes and almost every sort of
hearing is typically scheduled for 30
minutes
and my aim in that time is to get the
hearing done
and if the hearing doesn't take the
whole 30 minutes my aim is to get
started on writing the order
some hearings will take more than 30
minutes that's inevitable although the
parties are told when they get the
notice that the hearing is being
scheduled for 30 minutes or if it's for
longer for an hour or two hours or
whatever they know that in advance but
if you have a complicated case with
several different different issues and
sometimes if you have attorneys the
cases are going to run over the 30
minutes and it's my job to manage that
docket so that at the end of the day
I'll be able to have conducted all of
the hearings within the time allotted
so sometimes that leaves me time to
write the orders and sometimes it
doesn't and it's the unusual day when I
get all of my orders done by the time
the last hearing is done more typically
I'm working on orders after hours to get
as many of the orders done as I can and
obviously triaging orders that can be
done quickly orders that are expedited
that have an urgent need and taking a
little more time and setting aside
orders that may be final orders after
contested final hearings so that I have
a chance to digest what I've heard to
look at exhibits if there are exhibits
and to sort of recreate the testimony in
my head so that I can make those
and the emergencies and the other things
just sort of fill in the gaps so if I
have a break for some reason in the
middle of the day that's unexpected I'll
check with the clerk to see what I can
do and if nothing else there's always
there are always files downstairs for me
to look at and sign
on difficult cases or final hearings
that may be a full day sometimes
multi-day final hearings typically
involve exhibits they'll typically
involve testimony of multiple Witnesses
I take notes on my laptop in the
courtroom that's just a personal
idiosyncrasy of mine and folks get used
to the noise after a while but it really
helps me
recreate what I've heard and work with
what I've heard so that if I do a
contested final hearing when I get to
writing the case I'll reprint my notes
and read them and I'll look at the
exhibits and that way I have a fresher
flavor if it's been a couple of weeks
before I get started working on the case
I'll be able to recreate it to work on
writing time is precious for any circuit
court judge who works in the Family
Division there is not really enough
writing time
I'm typically behind and I say that
knowing the judge Ashley who's in charge
of keeping track of that sort of thing
is sitting here
um
but
I've always felt as though
doing an order that's the best order you
can do makes it worth the time and so I
don't sacrifice quality for time when I
write my orders
um
the
contested final hearings particularly in
cases in cases that involve children are
difficult even if there are attorneys
involved they're difficult for the
litigants
there is a there's an intrusiveness
that's inherent in the court system
people don't like someone else making
decisions about their children's lives
and that's
of course why would you why would anyone
the system though is designed ultimately
to allow that to happen and require it
to happen when a decision has to be made
and the parties haven't been able to
reach decisions on their own but I want
to emphasize that in Family Division we
provide multiple opportunities for
parties to work together and to try to
create agreements on their own
particularly agreements that relate to
their children
so we have a first appearance process
which is basically a lecture given by it
used to be a live judge before covet and
now it's on video
that is given to folks who are in a
divorce with children or parenting cases
and they come to court or nowadays they
go online from home and they watch the
video and the video is basically a
description of the process
a description of the mediation part of
the process and an encouragement for the
parties to try to work out as many
agreements together as they can to take
advantage of mediation if they can do it
mediation is mandatory in in these sorts
of cases there are some exceptions if
there's a domestic violence order for
example both parties have to agree to
mediation and those mediations only take
place at the courthouse
but by and large folks will go to
mediation before they go to their first
contested Hearing in a parenting in a
case that involves children
our mediators are certified by the
marital the family
mediator board they are vastly
experienced the group of mediators that
we use in Laconia have been doing it for
more than a decade at least they have
hundreds of cases that they've done
they're really effective and so we
provide that off-ramp immediately in the
process and give the parties as much
opportunity and as much encouragement as
we can to try to reach as many
we also have the child IMPACT Program
which is another mandatory program it's
given by different
resource providers in different
communities but it's basically a short
program to help folks understand
the impact of divorce or Separation on
their children and to help folks develop
skills for managing the difficulties
that their children are going to
experience as part of that process it is
mandatory we don't get a lot of feedback
about it but the feedback that I've
gotten about it is that it can be
life-changing for folks who just don't
know how to talk to each other about
parenting issues and who really needs
some guidance about how to make that
work so we ask that folks do that
complete that program within 45 days of
the filing that happens sometimes but
not always but we remind them of it at
every opportunity and we expect that by
the time they're getting to a tested
hearing they're going to have done the
child IMPACT program and they'll have a
have an understanding of what that
expectation is
the parenting plan form itself which I
hope you have a chance to look at at
some point you should look at that form
it's an eight or nine page form and it
was designed by designed by a committee
that took a lot of different points of
view into account the language in the
form is is generally the committee's
language but parents are always
encouraged to modify the form or change
it or not use it or pick language that
works for them and for their children
but it is a sort of a shorthand way of
describing a child's life
there's almost everything you can think
about that would impact a child's life
that has a place in that form we expect
if we don't expect parents to really
have a good sense of any of the other
forms within the Family Division we do
expect that they become familiar with
the parenting plan at least to be able
to go through it with each other
and if they're not able to reach
agreements to be able to present their
version of it to the court at a
contested final hearing
it's a critical document
it's intended to be user friendly for
folks who may not have much experience
with the court system
and it can be very valuable for the
court in analyzing what's going to be in
the children's best interest based in
part upon what each parent is proposing
happen with them so I would encourage
you to have a look at that at that Forum
that's that's our sort of go-to form in
terms of parenting
may I interrupt you at this point with a
couple of requests number one could you
get that form
to us either one copy to my committee
assistant or
16 copies for each member of the
committee and then secondly a question
if one or both of the parents refuse to
go through one of the programs or work
on the document what structures do you
have for them certainly the
the mediation part of it if
if there's a domestic violence order in
place both parties have to agree to go
to mediation if either of them doesn't
want to go to mediation we won't do it
so that's an automatic opt-out we don't
inquire about the reasons
there are some factors that might be
present in some cases which would exempt
folks from mediation and
um
I'm going to go back now about four or
five years before pandemic when I was
doing the first appearance
I would describe those factors to the
folks who were in the courtroom if they
felt it one of the factors might apply
to them then we'd have a brief hearing
immediately after the first appearance
session they could tell me why they
don't want to go to mediation I would
consider that and in some cases they
would be exempt from going to mediation
but the presumption is that they will go
if they don't go to mediation then
there are some fact there are some
consequences that could take place
technically it's a court order that you
go to mediation they could be found in
contempt I've I've never seen that
happen because I'm not quite sure what
the sanctions would be
more likely the mediator would report
that they didn't settle the case or one
party didn't show up and they'd be put
back onto the litigation track which is
just what's your next contested hearing
one might assume that the party that
refuses if it be one of the two it might
be taken into account in any judgments
shouldn't be shouldn't be I wouldn't
okay
partly because what happens in mediation
is completely confidential okay we don't
learn at all and we're very careful
about not learning what people say to
each other in mediation or what the
mediator might have said to them and
consistent with that I would never
inquire about someone why they didn't go
to mediation unless they had expressed
say there was a hearing in front of me
and they said of course we want to go to
mediation we're going to do this then if
the mediator filed a report saying that
this person just didn't participate
didn't show up didn't explain why none
of that I might have some question for
judgments about what will be in the best
interests of children are not affected
by A party's
unilateral choice not to participate in
mediation it's a separate process it's a
very successful process
but it's not a process that that is
going to result in an adverse
consequence in terms of your parenting
rights if you don't participate thank
you representative Bickford with a
uh you've mentioned family law committee
we created and we
parenting plans was something I brought
forward with uh John Cameron how are
they working out
um would you rather go back to something
else do you and do you need new tools to
I would say the parenting plan has been
a great success oh it's this it's a
straightforward form folks can read it
they can go through it
um it provides options for them it
provides ample space for them to write
their own orders and it's a document
that parents can sit down across a table
and work through in a Cooperative way
even if it's not a Cooperative way the
mediators are so familiar with the
parenting plan that they can help the
parents understand the nuances they can
even suggest language that might work
and ultimately it's it works because it
empowers parents to achieve these
agreements for themselves
so I would say that's been a great
success there are
there are bits and pieces of language in
there that with the benefit of a decade
of experience or so we could tweak but I
wouldn't make any wholesale changes to
the parenting plan that's been great and
and I would say the same thing of
mediation we have a high success rate in
mediation we encourage people to do it
in fact um
part of the package for mediation is
that you get five hours
and some folks are they're almost always
scheduled for a two-hour session to
begin with and then if they're not
successful they come back onto the sort
of contested hearing track but
if you've scheduled a final hearing and
sadly we're like most courts I think
we're months out scheduling a final
hearing at least several months out
you have that time and the folks can use
the rest of their five hours in
mediation so you really get at least two
shots at it to try to make the mediation
part of it work and I think it's been
very successful
uh we do have two more questions that I
will accept and then we're going on to
the next speaker and thank you so much
we'll have to have you guys back again
chair recognizes the clerk
thank you Mr chair thank you your honor
for taking the question
um what recourse does an individual have
if the other party is in violation of
the uh the parental plan the parenting
plan
typically there are two sorts of claims
that are made there one is a claim for
contempt the parenting plan once the
court has approved it is a court order
and the sanctions for contempt can be
sort of wide-ranging which could include
um
could include a fine it could include I
mean in an extreme case it could include
incarceration although I've never had
the Opera never had the had to make that
decision that's not usually on the table
it could um
include a limitation on a person's
ability to actively engage in certain
issues in the case
and um
ultimately it could be a part of an
order that might take into account the
question whether there's been
um an unwarranted interference with the
other party's parenting rights so that's
one of the standards under 461a11 by
which you can modify an existing final
order so if a parent is interfering with
the other parent's parenting rights it
could be by contempt it could be by not
following the parenting plan
that might be a basis for modification
of those orders again that would require
a separate request to modify just in
terms of the sanctions it's it's
basically a fine
of potentially incarceration limitation
on ability to to participate in the case
there could there could be others the
court has some discretion in terms of
the imposition of certain kinds of
sanctions
um and so it might be appropriate in
some cases to issue a sanction that's
more directly related to a parenting
issue but you have to be discreet about
it it has to be a one-time thing
thank you and final question for this
group of people representative Vice
chairman long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you judge
very good information
um if uh I believe it was four or five
terms ago all conflict divorces were
handed to a particular judge who did all
that
it appears that that is not the case
anymore high high conflict cases were
handed to one particular judge who did
all those you mean the complex case
talking correct certainly
um in my memory is that that was Judge
Foley at the time correct and it was a
Statewide program and judge Foley took
cases they were vetted to make sure they
were high conflict cases but he had a
docket of them and he was able to focus
exclusively on that docket and he was
very experienced so he was able to
manage those cases in a way that none of
the rest of us would have the time and
in some cases the experience to do
um and I'm aware that in Hillsboro
Hillsboro
okay now judge
judge the year some of you were on this
committee last year but judge Lemire
handles our complex docket now and again
it's similar to what judge Garner
described it's for the those cases that
might need
seven eight nine days of trial and
Incredibly complex and issues or
particularly difficult circumstances in
a particular case we still have the
ability to do that but but not nearly
enough so we do have judges in all of
our courts handling handling matters
that are in Conflict unfortunately great
thank you certainly
and thank you so much before you go I I
know there are other questions and I
have one too and mine will not be asked
either because we have another speaker
thank you
um you mentioned earlier whom we get in
touch with not you
who is the one that should we have an
appropriate question not about a
particular case who do we talk to
um so thank you Mr chairman uh you can
always ask email me uh call me or I'll
be in this uh in your meetings
frequently all questions can come
through me after uh we're done here
today I'm going to be emailing out the
parenting plan form to the group and the
dockets that the judge mentioned that
will have my email address my cell phone
address so you'll all have that
available to you I encourage you anybody
else questions
um you should feel free to reach out to
me thank you
10 seconds Mr chairman 10.
first don't hesitate with the questions
if I'm not allowed to answer something I
won't
but second if you have a chance come to
court
come to court and Watch What Happens
most of these Domestic Relations cases
are public cases the public can come in
and watch and listen I think it's the
it's the best way to get a handle on
what happens in the courtroom and to get
real
on the spot experience about what these
folks are going through and and how
dramatic these cases can be and how
challenging they can be not for us but
for the folks who are involved in the
cases so please come to court come to
Laconia I'll show you around thank you
so much I have a private tutorial every
Thursday evening with Sam Waterson
and 20 years of reruns over the summer I
and now the office of the child
Advocate come on up and introduce
good morning Mr chairman thank you for
having me here today my name is
Cassandra Sanchez I am the child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
and I have with me Jennifer Jones and
she is an assistant child advocate with
we currently have a vacant position of
the associate child advocate
which is an attorney position for our
office they often spend quite a lot of
time here in legislature throughout the
session so with that position vacant if
I am unable or there are multiple
hearings at one time Jennifer would be
in filling in for myself so I wanted to
bring her here today and introduce her
to all of you
thank you so here we're passing around
some materials from the office
I have in with those materials it is a
brief copy of our strategic plan which
includes the mission and the vision of
the office as well as some as some of
our goals I attached with it my business
card in the office business card my
business card will have my direct cell
phone contact if you have any questions
specific to bills or to topics which
maybe come before you that my office may
have some data or some information on
please do not hesitate to reach out
anytime you can reach me on my cell
and so I came to today prepared to
provide you a brief overview on the
office
um and leaving plenty of time for
questions and and comments if needed
so to share my office's independent
oversight over child serving entities
within the executive branch agency so
that includes the department of the
division of children youth and families
as well as
other child serving agencies so that it
would include the Department of
Education we have oversight as well over
the Bureau of children's Behavioral
Health which provides a lot of the
community-based services at this point
those community-based services that were
previously served under the Division of
Youth and children family services are
is now located under the Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health and we also
have oversight over the
organizations private or non-profit
organizations that contract with State
agencies so this allows our oversight
over all the residential facilities
as well as additional community-based
services that are contracted with either
dcyf or the Bureau of children's
Behavioral Health
in our daily work we have a multi-tiered
focus we do work at the case level so we
will get complaints that come into our
office in regards to children involved
in the juvenile justice system receiving
those community-based services or
involved with dcyf and on those cases we
will do we don't necessarily call them
investigations but we do do some reviews
of the system to ensure that they are
operating in the ways in which they
should that they're following their own
policies procedures and the laws that
exist and if they are not we will then
meet on those independent cases and make
recommendations to ensure that they do
follow the policies and laws
and so that is a good chunk of the work
that the assistant child advocate here
Jennifer Jones does as well as another
assistant child advocate in the office
so they do that independent case work
and managing the complaints that come
into the office
we also track those complaints in our
own computer system so that we can
follow Trends over time and we can
collect data and we use that data and
Trends to report back I do monthly
reporting to the oversight Commission on
children's services so we share there a
lot of the data and trends that we're
seeing and we also share them through
hearings if there's a hearing on a
particular topic that we've collected
data and we have found Trends we will
ensure that we provide that information
here before you or other committees
typically it would be child and family
law Health and Human Services primarily
but there are times that the office also
ends up in House Education
so that's that that higher level and
then we also work with the agency on
improving their own policies and
practices so taking a look at best
practice around the country we do a lot
of research focused on Child Development
on brain development and a focus on Aces
and we'll use that research and we will
advise on changes that they can make to
the system to improve the well-being for
of children in the state of New
Hampshire
with the division we also work with the
Bureau of children's Behavioral Health
doing much of the same at this point
there's a lot of research backing the
evidence-based treatments a lot of which
have already rolled out in our state and
so we always do help advocate for
additional positions to fill that
because we see the need in the community
is extremely high there's a lot of
Acuity with our children across the
state right now so we're always
advocating for additional positions in
the evidence-based
practices that are available right now
as well as seeking out others that are
utilized in other areas in the country
that we could potentially bring to the
state of New Hampshire
so as I mentioned we see high needs of
children at this time and what I mean by
that is the mental health needs of the
children across New Hampshire has
exacerbated over time we do believe a
lot of that is due to the impact of
coven and so we are watching that very
closely and really working to see the
ways in which providers are serving
families that are effective in helping
spread that across the state but with
that we have seen a need of children
continuing to wait in emergency rooms
awaiting that higher level inpatient
Care at Hampstead Hospital
and if unable to be serviced at
Hampstead Hospital unfortunately we're
finding that many of those families are
left without any follow-up or any
ability to connect with other systems
for care so we do receive some of those
through complaints and when we do we
ensure to refer them to the appropriate
service and ensure follow through for
that family that they were able to work
with that service to get the help that
they need in their family home
but that is a small impact so we try to
do that on a larger level through
education and Outreach and so we will do
education and Outreach with Community
provider agencies so that if they are
seeing
families struggling with more complex
needs than they can meet that they can
refer those families to our office and
they know how to do so and we will also
do it with parent groups and with
children as well we often spend a lot of
time going out to the residential
facilities and meeting with children
ensuring that they that our number is
visible because children do have the
right to call our office at any time and
so we ensure that the facilities are
posting our numbers so children can see
that and that they know how to access
our office as well as offering them
times when we are out there to sit down
and meet with us individually one-on-one
for confidential conversation so they
can report any concerns that they may
have
who designed your business card
it's incredible it's got your name and
then it says the child advocate
what do you have a cape too I mean this
is cool really cool Sorry representative
Grossman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here I'm curious
do does that happen often where kids do
reach out
um calling the office or during these
confidential conversations that you have
when you visit a facility
are they using that yes they are we've
really put a concerted effort into
ensuring that the office is known as a
resource and this has taken some time
with Cova there's been a lot of barriers
to that so this past year we've really
put an effort into being face to face
and meeting with these children so that
when they put a face to the name of the
office they knew they know who they're
calling they knew who they're going to
see on the other end of the phone and we
have received a lot more calls that way
we have children that we've connected
with in person at a facility and
something may occur a month or two later
and they're picking up the phone and
they're calling our office and they're
connecting with us so we are tracking to
see if we just finished our last annual
report so to see if our numbers from
last year increase from this coming year
and just by the numbers that we were
getting for calls so far in this annual
year so our annual year starts October
1st so the numbers that we've received
the number of calls we've received from
October to present
appears to already be an increase from
last year so those efforts seem to be
working
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
your presentation uh with respect to the
reports that you give to Children's
Services committee
um are those copied to CFL chairman or
I don't know are they posted on your web
they are posted on our website I do not
believe that they are are copied that is
something that we can do but currently I
do provide them in person during the
meetings and then we will post them on
the website so they are publicly
accessible
how often did you say how often those
those meetings are monthly um just
skipping the summer months so you report
monthly yes okay great thank you thank
you
I should know the answer to this because
I was the chairman of it for two years
do you regularly or periodically or once
in a great while report to DHHS
oversight committee
that is that the oversight commission
that takes place monthly yeah yeah but I
chaired for two years yeah I think you
were there weren't you I was not at that
time oh good it was my predecessor at
that time
you know what I mean yeah well I'm back
on it I don't know whether I'll share it
or not but we'll see you again oh
wonderful one of the issues that comes
up periodically with some of us as
Representatives is we get a constituent
with a grievance and say do something
about it and
we can't always do something about it in
a policy committee because our purpose
is to examine and maybe change laws not
run grievances
it's a Temptation if somebody's all
steamed up and we kind of think they may
be right that we want to do something
here where that goes in these cases of
children is to your office would that be
correct yes that is appropriate the DHHS
also has an ombudsman which we refer to
frequently but families can be guided in
our Direction and we would help them
with those steps in ensuring that they
know how to access the DHHS Ombudsman if
they had not done so already and once
they do reach out to the Ombudsman and
if they feel their problem has not been
resolved we oftentimes will look in the
case ensuring as long as we have the
jurisdiction over the issue that they're
taking a look at there are times that we
will get calls about
difficulties with their caseworker and
we will refer to the DHHS Ombudsman and
inform that that is not something that
we would look to resolve but if there is
a specific issue with what is happening
with their child on their case we would
be happy to look into it so before
referring out and just sending them off
we we do a lot of Education around
working with the system ensuring that
they know the steps and the appropriate
parties that they need to be in contact
with on their case so yes we do accept
referrals we get them often
no different reps or Senators as well
where they'll be receiving calls from
families that feel that they have
exhausted the system and do not have
anywhere else to go and we always do our
best to help them did I hear you
possibly suggest that one calls the DHHS
Ombudsman first before they call your
office did I hear that
so when we have a caller or complainant
call into our office we are required to
ask if they have if if the issue sits
Within
the scope of the DHHS Ombudsman we do
have to inquire whether they have
interacted with the Ombudsman if they
have not we refer them there we will
hold their information until they
contact them and get back to us and let
us know whether the problem was resolved
or not but it is a requirement within
our statute that we send them to the
DHHS Ombudsman so it would save a dime
as as long as it is within their
jurisdiction because our jurisdiction is
broader we can cover more but yes if it
is a specific
um dcyf or Bureau of children's
behavioral health issue then yes the
DHHS Ombudsman would be the first touch
point and do you have that number handy
I can guess the first six but it's the
last four that's hard I don't have that
off the top of my head but I can send
that along okay I'm wondering if you
might have that for us I bet you will
thank you chairman um I just
representative Raymond thank you you got
it
um I just wanted to say I still have
that sheet that they passed out last
week so I have the number for the
um budsman here if you want me to read
it aloud
please okay it's 603
-271
-3948
according to the sheet that DHHS gave us
last week
Maybe
you see yet again pieces of paper go
faster than computers
okay
and
we'll find out okay any other questions
thank you so much we'll be seeing you
again I know thank you for having me yes
as we get ready for opening our first
hearing a couple of things for the
members of the committee please members
of the committee who are co-sponsors of
bills
you can do one of two things you can
testify up there at the witness table if
you wish
if you do then when you come you are no
longer testifying you cannot ask
questions of anyone else you can either
stay up here and ask questions of
anybody who comes to testify or you can
be one who testifies
you do get a chance to speak later
during exec time on bills however
uh secondly
um again I've been asked to remind us as
other chairs are doing that what we try
to do here is ask questions and not
testify there'll be plenty of time for
that I know sometimes the question is a
leading question but uh we have to be
careful to make sure we're asking
questions
third a straightforward bill
uh easy peasy housekeeping
uh sometimes turn into three-hour
hearings but more normally they are
actually straightforward and they can be
exact immediately afterwards if the
chair and vice chair or excuse me the
chair and the ranking member who in this
case is also the vice chair if we agree
to do so
if we want to go on and accept something
to get things onto the calendar that
look like it will be an easy Bill if we
agree
otherwise it has to be scheduled we can
no longer do it later in the day if
there's a Time Gap
and fourthly uh Republicans this is for
you I get to recommend to the speaker
various people to serve on various
commissions and committees and I've sent
you emails and some of you have gotten
back to me actually I've sent a few
others and I know representative long
you're working the same kind of thing
um
and so uh some of you thank you you've
gotten back to me you said wow I'd love
to serve on the commission of such and
such
um
and that that'll go on to the speaker's
office others of you uh here's your
chance get back to me
representative login along that lines
for your folks
well thank you
these are fun for those of you who are
new to the house some of these can be
fun you learn all kinds of things you
get to meet a bunch of people that you
wouldn't be meeting here otherwise and
and now I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill
126 relative to choosing the accrual
date for child support payments and the
chair recognizes chairman Spillane to
come forward and present your bill
please
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um I'm hoping this is one of those
straightforward bills that we just had
heard about
um because I think that we all know that
uh
people are paid at different schedules
throughout the month these days not
everybody's paid weekly and one of the
things I ran into
um as I pay child support myself
currently is that um
the lining up of when you have to pay
and when your other bills are stacking
doesn't always work
but what I and and there was no option
for me to change that accrual date or
the the due date to another
date in the month like you can with your
mortgage you can often say I don't like
the first I'd rather be on the 15th or
I'd rather be on the seventh or
something like that because it works
better and so what I'm trying to do is
offer that flexibility of it I'd love to
see it be able to be so they could
choose any week in the month but I think
that a simple step forward is to give
them at least the choice of the the
beginning of the month or the middle of
the month and give them the choice of
either the first or the 15th for their
due date
um and that's all this bill does it uh
it basically changes that every single
child support payer in the state be on
the first to let's let child support
payer choose the first or the 15th
I'll take any questions if anyone has
any
representative Raymond
thank you chairman and uh thank you
representative Spillane I'm curious
about how this change would affect our
office of child our Department of Child
Support Services
at Health and Human Services because
right now they all pay process the
payments at the same time will that
change their staffing needs or their
operational needs in any way I don't
expect that it would have any change in
anything except for probably an update
to the system software wise to allow uh
the flexibility to happen
and for those people who have
um the pay taken out of their check it
wouldn't make any difference anyway
because it comes out every single pay
period and and they just continue
accruing constantly this would mainly
affect people who have another agreement
with their spouse and or pay in other
ways and so I think the department could
probably better answer that but whereas
as there was no fiscal note attached to
this I don't think there's a huge impact
and I cannot answer anything beyond
potentially a software update to allow
the first to the 15th is that something
that each person can choose every month
or is it set once they choose one
well I would imagine they could go and
ask for it to be changed in the future
if their employment changed because we
always have the ability if our
employment changes or some some major
thing changes to talk to uh Division of
Child Support Services about changing
how much child support or what have you
but that's usually done involving the
court and I would imagine that once they
choose their date that would be the date
unless something changed that they
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman thank you and
thank you for your testimony today can
you see of an impact on the payee with
like bills being due at the first of the
month or whatever what kind of impact
would this have to move it to the middle
if they have like the child care costs
or anything they're getting that payment
for
well again that that is that is a
potential uh thing that needs to be
looked at usually this date is not done
in isolation it's done in agreement
during the discussion on child support
during the court period
um and if the payments are coming on
time and never falling behind
then there wouldn't be a problem because
the person would always have that check
coming every month from Division of
if somebody falls behind then it becomes
more of a problem with them getting
their their pay on time their their
child support on time and falling behind
is something I'm trying to avoid with
this where somebody repeatedly is
falling behind every month because
everything's due on the first and they'd
be much
better
able to pay on a 15th then to try to
manage their finances to try to fit it
in with their mortgage or rent or
whatever those they're also paying at
thank you so that would then fall on the
payee to
um you know talk to their bill people
and say hey I'm not getting this till
the 15th so that they would need to
switch that unless it's you know they
are able to save up that half a month or
whatever well I imagine that if if
there's any issues where it needs to be
on the first and that's not going to
work out for them that would be brought
up in the child support discussion court
before it even happened or with the
mediator if an employment situation
changes because both parties get to
speak all the time right now anyway
about
um what their situations are and they
submit their financials and they talk
about the whole landscape of everything
before any decisions are made about how
much it is and and all this and whether
it's done automatically from pay
that's all discussed so
I would hope and I would imagine that
that discussion comes up when there's a
court mediator to say you know what your
your payee is not going to be able to
function on the 15th so as much as it
would work out for you we can't do that
would you assume that in uh the
conversations between a person and that
person's ex and the court
since we're moving from the first of the
month to the 15th of the next month
there might be a gap half months payment
otherwise we've some people could have a
problem
I guess it depends on when it would be
implemented as a as a change because
um if it's starting out with a brand new
case that has just been decided in court
there's been no payments yet it's going
straight on to child support on the 15th
if somebody's changing from the first to
the 15th I know that that Division of
Child Support Services often has to
manage when it comes out of pay that
doesn't happen on a weekly basis
um how to catch up
and so I've seen it myself with um where
they say now there's an additional x
amount due every period for the next
you know three pay periods to try to
catch up
Okay so
representative Grossman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for coming before us
so in your situation where you already
are in an agreement with a set due date
because you've gone through the process
how would this impact folks that already
have a set date because they've already
been through that process so it doesn't
describe in here any way that they could
change it they would have to petition to
the court to make a change to their
child support
and both parties can submit this without
an attorney it doesn't cost anything
they just have to submit a written
agreement between them that they want to
change it or the one person can petition
that they would like to change it and
send copies to the other person and then
they get into the discussion with the
mediator even if they both agree to it
it goes before the mediator to look at
their financials again discuss the
situation and decide whether they can
change to it if I was to to do that from
my case which I'm not interested in I'm
perfectly fine with where it's at but
um I would have to basically start that
process by discussing with my ex and
deciding do we want to do this jointly
do we both agree on this if so let's
just submit it we'll ask them to go
ahead and approve it
they'll look at it discuss things with
us and approve it or if we can't come to
agreement on it the mediator gets to
look at both situations and decide
is that person constantly falling late
and is that a problem versus is this
person needing that money on the first
is that the problem where do we come to
the middle but at least gives them the
flexibility to say works better for both
parties let's do it that way
follow up
do you think that this may create a
problem in the family courts though in
terms of dealing with two parties that
already may not I mean this is what the
heart of the matter in divorce
proceedings is
other than the children obviously but
the conflict resolution in terms of the
monetary so if now
the court people can go back and refile
for a new motion but they both have to
agree to file for that motion
so
okay let's not get too complicated on it
because I need to break these down as a
lot there
um
child support is always the most one of
the most contentious things in the
divorce custody and child support we
know that
none of it's done
outside of the Court
looking at the formulas and doing the
mediation on things and essentially
anytime I want to petition I had a
period uh three years ago where I lost
my job laid off during covid I had to
petition to the court to change the
that was a petition to the court
explained why new financials from both
parties we have to get on the phone they
look at the financials they run the
formula again they decide when it's due
this would just add one more aspect into
discussing the financials that says
would you like the due date on the first
or the 15th does that work for both of
you if not why
um it's not dragging open a new area
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question
um this is about public assistance the
bill
and so it doesn't trigger until there's
uh someone applies to say welfare
no no no see that it says on line three
made to or for the benefit of the
dependent child creates a debt due to
the department not to the child but to
the department because the child has
well it's already gotten this is under
the entire statute though I'm not sure
why they put it there um we can look at
that and figure out why they put it
there but this this is under the entire
section about when
the due date is to child support to the
Division of Child Support Services
um
and so it's supposed to be outside of
the public assistance area there is a
trigger within requesting for public
assistance that requires that it be
um garnished from wages yeah okay
um
but that
basically makes the question of the
first or the 15th move if it's being
garnished from the wages because it's
being taken out at every pay period at
that point so um
it's a good question why it starts with
that section on line three but it should
not be addressing that it should be
addressing
I have 161 C4 in front of me any payment
of Public Assistance made two or for the
benefit of a dependent child creates a
debt due and owing to the department by
any responsible parent except as
otherwise provided in 161 C5 the amount
of debt shall be equal to the
calculation and it goes on into a bunch
of numbers
it's
a modification of how that happens from
only
on the first to what you propose so
that's why it's worded as it is it's
getting us a running Head Start
by quoting that whole little section
and
my further assumption would be then that
they consider the fact that you have a
debt owed that's paid through the
Department of Child and Family Services
as being
a route through the public assistance
area because they handle the payment the
payment goes to
Division of Child Support Services which
is then
passed along to the parent
yeah
that's the section yeah
you may have just follow up yeah follow
up
um so
based on your testimony it sounds like
you need to get back into another piece
of the law to cover what you want to
accomplish
and you so I'm just I guess I trusted
the experts in this area to put it in
the right place and I'm hoping that this
committee can also make sure it's in the
right place but it should be
governing all of the due dates for child
support
um regardless of whether it's garnished
or not because it wouldn't make any
difference but to basically change that
um due date so that the person had the
flexibility to decide
any further questions for
Representatives belaying the Bill's
Prime sponsor seeing none thank you so
much thank you members of the committee
and the chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
she wishes to speak for three minutes
thank you
and you are rising in opposition to the
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is Vivian Gerard a
formerly Silva and a lot of you probably
know me as a Silva V Silva case I
disagree with this bill and I don't
think it makes any difference putting a
date on the child support So passing
this bill is very irrelevant and I
believe as you had said that it really
goes back to the tandiff cases
um
where this really is it doesn't make
sense
so um from my experience
um I've been
I've had 25 herons and five appeals
basically on child support
um I can tell you that I mean granted I
did have three bad judges but I can see
how this bill would work more with
somebody that is a W-2 employee
if somebody is self-employed
this doesn't make sense for them and if
anything is only going to hurt them more
if anything I would say make an
amendment to this bill and
have it so if somebody is self-employed
and I am as well so I can really relate
to this but I'm on the opposite side of
life here I'm the one collecting the
paychecks my ex is a w two earner
um so I think that if somebody struggles
paying their child support
that if anything you would give them
somewhat of a grace period for 60 days
to make up that amount that they could
not pay so putting a date on there for
say the 15th whether they're a
self-employed employee or not it really
doesn't matter
um and and the other part that I really
have a hard time with is the Department
of child's child support
is so quick to pull somebody's driver's
license if you do not make that date and
the sad thing is
um that is preventing them from paying
it and we'll set them back even further
um I've been sitting at the um
Courthouse listening to these child
support cases because I'm very
interested in how this stuff happens
and they are very quick to put a
criminal penalty on these people that
miss that one day and they're not
looking at it as okay this is a
self-employed person rather than
somebody that's a W-2 earner
so I feel that um
putting these dates on again is very
irrelevant because if you're dealing
with somebody that makes a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year they have
no problem whether the the dates on the
first of the 15th
um
so in my case yes this caused quite a
bit of strain on my family financially
and my ex even though he is a W2 earner
and he was supposed to pay it on a
certain day he paid what he wanted when
he felt like it so the dates were very
irrelevant for him and the gentleman
that spoke before me made it so easy to
sound like oh just go up and ask for
another date it's not like that it is
very contentious and me above all people
can tell you I've been in the court
system for nine years and I still don't
have an order on my child support
um basically for the arrears granted
again I had three bad judges so it
really is not
um helpful in that case but I think that
this would be very dangerous to families
and individuals sorry individuals where
if you start putting these limitations
on them and put in certain dates again I
don't think that they need anything are
you willing to take questions you're
starting to repeat yourself so and
that's good I mean it's good that you
said what you did but uh would you take
any questions absolutely
I see none thank you for your testimony
okay and also I do have um a couple of
handouts here because if you could give
them at the end of the table and pass
them down absolutely thank you so much
the chair now recognizes Matthew Hayes
it lists to represent the Department of
Health and Human Services o b c s s
Bureau of
children childish childhood thank you Mr
chair I get most of the letters yes the
Bureau of Child Support Services got it
foreign
so I just like to say I thank you Mr
chair and members of the house uh
children and family law committee on
behalf of the State of New Hampshire and
the Department of Health and Human
Services the funeral child support I
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak about hb126
I am a staff attorney for the Bureau of
Child Support also in the legislative
liaison my name is Matthew Hayes
um the mural of Child Support is
essentially uh created out of the
child's um
tunnel 14 and the Social Security Act of
1975 and is charged with the
responsibility of enforcing child
support orders in the state of New
Hampshire
um I'd like to just uh bring out a few
uh statutes to know committee's
attention that might conflict with this
bill
um my wave definition uh child support
arrears represent the amount of child
support that remains unpaid it is owed
either to the family or the government
when a family applies for public
assistance such as TANF temporary system
could you quote since I have the
statutes here would you be willing to
quote them as you read them yes um I can
and I also have a handout that provides
one of the ones I'm going to talk about
the most I have a number of copies I can
leave here that everyone can look at
after but essentially I'm talking a
little bit about
um
on rears because
this statue does appear to be placed in
a statute that talks about public
assistance so I was addressing that
generally in our situation when we
enforce cases the arrears are
essentially IR owed to us
because a child support owner accrued
during a time where an obligene was
receiving TANF assistance in which case
those accruals would belong to the state
but in particular I draw on the
committee's attention to RSA 458
excuse me B4
3 which this statute essentially deals
with
wage assignments and in particular that
provision deals with the amount that's
withheld when an employer is withholding
child support that employer must
withhold a sufficient amount to meet the
obligation the ongoing obligation
as well as an extra 20 percent that goes
towards payment on arrears
um so
I think that has to be rent to show that
um when
the employer takes the money that
employer doesn't really have an option
to uh bifurcate you know oh this is
going to be applied to the ongoing Sport
and and this will go apply to
10 FM readers and I'm I'm not entirely
sure when I prepared this testimony I
know there's a couple different
directions I thought maybe this could go
so I'm just trying to provide the
convenience general information about
where I think conflicts might exist
um I think in particular the committee
should be aware of also in that same
statute 458 B6
uh this that provision deals with uh
employers and requirements of employers
in particular paragraph four requires
the employer to send
withheld amounts immediately
to the payee or the department they're
not permitted to just hang collect it at
a certain time of the month
uh almost maybe an escrow
and then provide that at a later date
they have to immediately
pay those funds when the employer
receives them or when the employee
receives them
um I also have a quick
I have another stature I want to talk
about but I don't know if it would be
easier to take the question or if the
hit if the committee is finding what I
said already helpful but before you do
is it your testimony that the bill
before us
um should have been placed in 458b
rather than where it is assigned here
I think it would be problematic I think
that what the bill is trying to
accomplish sounds to me problematic with
the whole structure of the payments in
general
um it seems to conflict with how wage
garnishments work and it does seem to
conflict with how accruals of the child
support work and the other statute I was
going to talk about
was the nature of the child support
order itself all child support orders in
New Hampshire are judgments and
according to a different statute RSA 461
A14
all support payments ordered or
administered by the court
[Music]
under this chapter shall be deemed to
judgments when due and payable
so
the bureau as at this point isn't taking
a position necessarily uh or or against
I put neutral on my card hope that's
okay
um I just think that some of these
statutes definitely seem to apply and it
seems
um just sort of
they don't mix very well with
structuring a date that's due on at the
oblique horse choice on the first or the
15th of the month
um so I I'm just going to conclude as
far as my written testimony I do have
that I can submit
um I'm happy to take questions and I've
also included my card on the information
representative long thank you thank you
Mr chairman
um thank you for your testimony uh now
my understanding from a bill last term
that there are some court orders that
don't have a date
you're ordered to pay 145 dollars a week
um and as my understanding is there well
well are you of that understanding that
there are some court orders that don't
specify a date
um the court order the uniform support
order
it doesn't provide an exact date what it
would do is it says the effective date
of this order is
um you know to January 17 of 2023 that's
the first let's say that's the first
date that the order goes into effect
and somebody is to pay 144 dollars per
week I think that's what you said
um effective January 17 2023. today's a
Tuesday so essentially every Tuesday
that will be an accrual
um that obligation becomes due on this
date
um
my apologies
follow up thank you Mr chairman
um and uh are you aware that some people
that are getting the child support
have a difficult time because it's
sporadic so it's not a specific date
it's yeah
you get it one month at the first week
you get it another month at the third
week you get in another month off the
second week is is that are you aware of
that situation happening
um unfortunately you know wage
garnishment is the preferred method for
collecting child support unfortunately
when there is not a wage garnishment for
example if somebody is self-employed
it's it's difficult you're relying on
them to make the payments and if they
don't
um there's certain enforcement remedies
that can happen if it's payable through
us
um parties are certainly willing to file
motions to contempt if it's not payable
through us but
um yes unfortunately some people do not
make payments on time and without a wage
garnishment
it's sort of on them to make them on
time and that doesn't always happen
thank you
um
it's not a matter of not
paying support for the month it's just a
matter of paying at different times
where the recipient of the child support
is getting paid at different times so
this month I'm getting paid on the first
week
the next month on the third week so
there's it's not consistent it's not
that
the person paying is missing the payment
it's the day that he pays so I'm asking
you I you know you said that this bill
would be problematic I'm asking you if
that would suffice if you pick a time
uh that would be cons that would draw
more consistency
I just feel that they're already there
already are due dates and this I guess
uh spells out
you know once a month like you could
already have a court order that in a
cruise once a month on the first of the
month I mean parties could agree to that
and then on the first of the month they
owe 800
um and then they have to pay it and then
if they don't there's certain things
that can happen but
um that's how my that's my understanding
of how the court order Works
um you know it's a judgment essentially
and it is payable when do
representative Raymond
thank you chairperson and thank you Mr
hat to explain this to us can you I ask
a question in a little bit broader
context could you tell us please
um
approximately
um how many of the cases of Child
Support like what's the ratio between
ones that are wage garnished through
your office versus you know people
having just a court order and working it
out because as I'm reading this I'm
confused as to how as to whether or not
this bill would affect the people who
are being waged garnished or only people
uh I mean I I think that thank you for
the question
um representative I don't I'm not sure
and you if you're looking for numbers as
far as how many cases we have wage
garnishments out as far as how many
cases we enforce I'd have to get those I
don't know I have them on top of my head
but I think there could be a way to do
it
um
it sounds like and again I I don't want
to presume something in the bill I'm
just sort of
I'm not sure exactly how it fits in
based on where it's been placed but
it I don't want to be repetitive but it
does seem too conflict I mean the money
if you have a wage garnishment set up
and it's whether it's
um
a tan of case or not TANF case the
employer is told by ours our Bureau that
if this person gets paid bi-weekly this
is how much you take out this will help
cover
the ongoing support and it'll help go
towards the arrears it's sort of
happens a little bit separate from the
way in which they crew so sometimes in a
cruel happened and then next social
happens an employee gets paid you know
the next week so as long as the payments
have been coming in every month then
they continue to be in compliance
it's almost like they're sort of
it's just a couple different ways
there's a couple different components to
the payments in in the child support
world thank you
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman I'll be quick and thank you for
taking my question so what you're saying
is there's no according to what the
information that you have there's no
set like it has to be on the first it's
kind of individual judgments so maybe
making a law where it's one of two dates
could complicate it sorry I'm just
trying to wrap my head around all of it
um I think it I think it could
complicate things especially if a court
would order that the payments are
supposed to be weekly
um the court might order you know in in
the best interest of the child that you
know I think the payment should be 144
per week so in theory the obligation to
be getting paid 144 dollars per week
um
so there's there's that practical aspect
of it
um I have a question isn't it really
your Department's concern
that you take money in
and pay money out and the specifics are
really between the parties and the court
system the department is basically just
the bank
uh that is we that is part of a role and
I think that
um
I think the issue where it gets
complicated is if this does conflict
with wage garnishment statutes so those
wage cars with statutes are
mandated by federal law CFR and I'm not
saying this seeks to change that I'm
just saying if there are conflicts with
the way in which the department is able
to get money into the obligies and again
this this was placed in the
Public Assistance portion of the statute
so that was another reason why the
bureau had to be here um I think to help
explain what our thoughts are
okay I've just read the support section
461 so it maybe should have gone there
and that's not a question but it should
have been representative Bickford
thank you Mr chair thank you uh Mr Hayes
um
back some time ago when the federal
government came to us and said you're
going to have to do wage assignment or
you're going to lose 21 million dollars
um we did come up with an option which
was to allow people to have some I can't
remember the checking account or some
kind of account where a person could put
their money in
and then take it out thanks to our vice
chair Randy Lyman at the time is that
still in existence
uh I think parties if you uh thank you
for your question sir um representative
yes people can wave out of wage
garnishments
um if they're if the court orders that's
in the best interest of the case then
there's Provisions for that in there and
we are able to
um have a part of our department
essentially take the money in and and
provide it to the other theology so
there's certainly many cases where we
don't uh have very little involvement in
the case
other than taking the money in uh and
dispersing it to your point Mr chair
thank you for example isn't it to your
point that liens are mentioned or the
requirement of a previous pay or to go
on food stamps and again that is really
not your concern as long as the
department gets the money that it will
then expense
um am I correct in assuming that you'd
the department does not actively do the
liens on property or the legal
requirements of getting food stamps I'm
not sure about food stamps but I know
for liens if if there's an order payable
through us then and we're charged with
the enforcement of that order then liens
are one of our enforcement tools and
that's something that the department
would do
okay thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
and you had some stuff for us I think
you said I do would you like me to yeah
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
to the committee my name again is
Deborah D Simone I represent Atkinson
Rockingham 18.
when I saw this bill
and spoke with the sponsor of the bill
he did a little bit of research and one
of the issues or a few of the issues
that hasn't been brought up yet so far
is
um
the consistency of payments whether they
be through garnish mint of wages or
personal pay
it has been brought up and the
discussion has been made concerning the
fact that somebody could get their child
support on January 2nd but then not see
it until February 28th
so this would create more consistency
but one of the more serious issues
I think is
that
there are many times where your child
support payments if in the case of
garnishment
goes to
DHHS and you get paid on the 15th but
they're expecting your payment on the
10th and in the interim you apply for a
passport because your employer is
sending you to another country for work
your passport will be denied because
you're behind on child support
in the case of a similar case you apply
to renew your driver's license and your
driver's license renewal will be denied
because you're behind on child support
payments even though your monthly salary
bi-weekly bi-monthly salary or whatever
is garnished so I think we need to take
that into consideration that this bill
could create more consistency and people
who are up to date on their child
support payments would no longer be
considered
delinquent
thank you for your time
does anyone have any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chairman as much as I had
hoped we could go to an exec session on
this the ranking member and I both
are of the opinion that the prime
sponsor might wish to check with
an attorney to see if what he requests
could be cited differently I wrote down
the RSA numbers here if you want them
later it does seem to me to fit better
there and it might
um not lead to the confusion that some
are I believe having by it being way in
the front of the book and so we're going
to hold on to this and come back with um
some perhaps different sightings
so thank you
and that closes the hearing on House
and now I open the hearing on House Bill
108.
and although he needs no introduction
I'm supposed to do it representative
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee again
um this bill is one that I worked hard
on the last term uh with the directors
is it Commissioner of dcyf
um
we amended it we amended it again we
came up with language that really worked
well we got it passed through the house
and it stalled in the Senate and ended
up retained while they looked into
things
um but
this was
done with the agreement of division of
child uh children youth and families
dcyf to try and
place in place
at least
um a penalty for making false claims to
dcyf
as things stand in the state of New
Hampshire I can pull a fire alarm and I
can get charged for it
uh if there's no fire I can make a call
into the police with there not being a
real threat and I can get charged with
that false claim but I can call in on my
neighbor because they threw trash on my
lawn and say they're abusing their kids
and there's no penalty even if I did it
maliciously with bad intent to try to
get dcyf involved in their family
there's no penalty at all
there's nothing that can be done
so
the big point of this bill is
that we did not
make the bar easy to get over it's a
high bar it says that they must make the
accusation maliciously and with bad
intent with intent to harm
so
there's
agreement that there would be very
little chance that a first-time person
who was concerned about a child and did
call would ever get charged with this
but a person who repeatedly calls and
makes false complaints that they can
actually make the the proof in court
that the person did it maliciously and
with intent to harm
um they could be charged with this so
that it could serve as a deterrent from
people making false accusations and
using the department
um
as a weaponized way to get back at a an
ex or another family that took uh
custody of the children temporarily or
what have you
so the first part of the bill simply
says that the first around line 10
you'll see that it says that reports
made to the department may include the
name address or phone number originally
I had wanted to get rid of all Anonymous
reports turned out not a great idea to
make that jump forward but let's let's
try to discourage Anonymous reports
whenever possible so
um we're leaving it up to the person
taking the call at dcyf to ask for that
information if they want to and if the
person is is really adamant they want to
do it anonymously they can still do that
we did not change that at all we've just
put in the ability that they they have
written here now they have the ability
to make a reminder I was told last term
from the um
director of dcyf that the staff that
takes these calls is few in number
and they tend to get to know certain
people who are repeat callers
so they can remind them that there's a
criminal statute once this passes and
say do you really want to make this
complaint
when they know when they recognize the
caller somebody who's done been a repeat
caller
um
for unfounded cases but that is also a
may they don't have to tell them and
make that reminder it just gives them
the ability to ask for that and to make
that reminder
the only thing that's
that's
set in stone here that must be followed
is the fact that it is now as if you
look at line 22 we're adding the fact
that it will be a misdemeanor to
knowingly make false statements of
suspected child abuse
to the department to any Court to any
law enforcement agency or to any Social
Service Agency or to any mandatory
reporter of suspected child abuse
any person who knowingly or in bad faith
makes a false report of suspected child
abuse
may be subject to those penalties so it
has to be made with bad faith knowingly
you know that it's a false accusation
you make it anyway
and that's when this would kick in aside
from that we've preserved every ability
for somebody who has the slightest
inkling that there's abuse going on to
be able to make that call without any
fear of charges it's only for those Bad
actors who have shown repeatedly that
they've they we can now prove it in
court
foreign
representative panic thank you chairman
how can you prove a false claim
preponderance of evidence
um as I said this would never apply to a
first person because you can't prove
that somebody knowingly
made that that false accusation the
first time but I have had I have a
constituent
who lives in a part of the state not in
one of my towns but has reached out to
me last term
when this was going on
has been going through a divorce for
over three years
and was getting calls for child from
division of child support dcyf
every two or three weeks
because the
separated husband's new girlfriend was
making calls in to try to sway the
divorce process by getting on record
that there's an abuse going on so in
that instance it's repeated
there's proof that it's happening they
were anonymous
but I have no doubt that at some point
the department could put together a
pattern and identify the numbers the
calls are coming from or some such
there's no reason for them to try to put
that pattern together right now because
there's nothing they can do there's no
way they can charge somebody from
repeatedly making a false accusation
when this statute passes
they now have the ability to investigate
when those abuses are taking place and
this isn't just about
geez it's kind of annoying to have dcyf
called on me every three weeks this
causes emotional turmoil in the family
it causes
traumatic damage to the children that
are involved in it
um because they get pulled out of bed in
the middle of the night so an officer
can look for wounds on their body
and this also takes away vital resources
from dcyf that they could be putting on
other things
now in a discussion with the director
last time I was told that because of our
increase in the opioid problem one of
the problems they're finding now is that
a lot of placements are taking place
with the grandparents and you run into a
situation where this grandparent's upset
that that grandparent got custody and
this one didn't so this one's making
calls to dcyf about that grandparent
because they feel they should have had
custody instead
and the system is getting weaponized and
there's nothing that can be done by the
state to stop it at the moment
so I'm asking that you give serious
thought to passing this again we passed
it last year we didn't get it through
the Senate but I have every confidence
that this year we can get it through the
Senate and we can put a stop to the
representative Raymond
thank you Representatives Blaine I've
worked in a state that has this statute
I worked in New York for dcif there well
it's different agency but it doesn't
matter
um my question is regarding the part of
your bill here where it says may be
subject to criminal and civil penalties
so who are who would be tasks with
investigating whether this was
maliciously done
maliciously or falsely knowingly falsely
reported and then how does one approach
this in the civil court so I'm
envisioning police in my experience
police have gone out and done it good
question good question
um the thing we wanted to allow was that
such as in the instance of the um the
divorce situation where the claims were
being made repeatedly and disrupting the
lives of four children and a mother
that there was some ability for her to
civilly recover damages
after that
criminal charge was proven so that's in
there so that if it's proven by the
investigation of the department and the
police that this person has made these
uh repeated false accusations and is
guilty of the misdemeanor that then that
opens it up to a civil complaint that
can allow that person to recover damages
whether it be
counseling costs for the children
because of the incident
um lost days at work for the person who
was injured by the the calls made
against them that were false any of that
could be recovered civilly to allow them
to try to recover some Port of part of
would you believe that as a mandatory
reporter
the end the employer of several others
dropping a dime on people very seriously
and we really agonize about
when somebody did fall down versus
something else and we take it very
seriously and
speaking as both a mandatory reporter
I appreciate the restraint that you put
in here
thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
I started to say war paint but I decided
I'm guilty of horrible handwriting I
will admit that so I've seen worse
uh Mr chairman and members of the
committee good morning my name is Keith
kinning
um I'm the advocacy director at Waypoint
and I sit in opposition to this bill
um
life is about balancing
we have a balance here that we're trying
to figure out correct we're trying to
balance how do we protect children and
get people to call in when they think
something is wrong versus a law that
apparently is being used in some
occasions as the representative said as
a weapon
and so how do we find that balance
um in New Hampshire we are all mandated
reporters but most of us don't know what
abuse and neglect is and so when we see
something happening we're we are tasked
by the state to call in and Report
something and I think what the
representative said and I agree with two
words
um you don't want the law weaponized but
he's talking about the deterrence that
will happen to the people that are
making the false claims I would ask you
to look at from the point of view of the
deterrence that could happen from people
that are afraid to call in because they
are hearing that you can be charged with
a misdemeanor if you make a false report
and so I I guess what I'm saying to you
is if we started telephone like we did
when we were in fifth grade and we
started here with representative
Bickford and I talked about the bill and
I'd say you have to knowingly make a
false claim and you can end up with a
misdemeanor I bet by the time it got
down to representative Seidel probably
what people would hear was that if you
make a false claim you can be charged
with the misdemeanor and that is my fear
is that people will start to hesitate
when it comes to calling in rather than
just calling in and letting the
department decide
which
um cases should be followed up and which
shouldn't be followed up now in this
state the vast majority of cases are
unfounded there are thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
phone calls that happen in the state
every year and a relatively few end up
as founded cases and so we have decided
as a state we're going to err on the
side of letting people call in to make
sure that these kids are protected and
letting the state go from there
um so I guess the one part that I would
ask this committee is that if you decide
to go forward with this bill I would
recommend that you remove the
misdemeanors if you decide you want to
have civil penalties
that is that is in in my opinion a far
better way to go than people in the
community hearing that if they somehow
make a false statement and I know the
word is knowingly but if people don't
understand that and they hesitate we
won't have people calling in protecting
the children the Civil penalties are
tend to be less intimidating than a
misdemeanor charge would be
um but again this is a balancing act and
um I would ask the committee to consider
that as we go forward so I'll stop there
and see if there are any questions
question from the chair is that in those
states that have this
bill on the books is a law
has the number of people calling in
significantly plummeted yeah thank you
for the question I can't answer that for
you Mr chairman but I can look into it
for you I can I can look in to see if if
representative long
the chairman
um in your opinion could could
um civil action be taken currently
or does it have to be put into statute
I mean if somebody put a false claim on
me
could I simply go after that person I
guess thank you for the question I
wouldn't want I wouldn't want you to
hang your hat on this representative
along but I mean it would seem to me
that if you're continually being told
someone is saying something negative
about you that is false that's a
defamation under the law so I guess
under civil penalty you could do that
okay thank you
um
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um
if I was to go to the police and make a
false statement I would I would be
charged if I went to the court I'd be
charged however
is is there actual immunity
in the statute I I thought there was but
I can't remember is there immunity under
this chapter
from people
making false statements
um or could they be actually charged for
reporting falsely well thank you for the
question I don't think currently they
can be charged I think that the problem
becomes is most of us don't know what
the definition we don't know the legal
definition of abuse and neglect I think
representative Bickford this is what I'm
afraid of is that one day you see a
child standing out waiting for the bus
and they're standing in the rain and you
and you call in and nothing happens do
you mind if I continue or do you want I
understand that I
I was here when we fought when we passed
this yeah do you mind if I continue let
him continue please is that right well
and you call in and nothing is done and
then you call it and see in a week the
child is standing out there and they're
standing in the rain and they don't have
any coat on and then you call in and
then the next week you say them standing
out in the rain now all of those may
have been found unfounded by the
department at that point but if you're
calling in multiple multiple times
because you're seeing things that are
happening and this is what usually
happens with somebody that's a neighbor
um are you going to be at some point is
somebody going to say to you well you've
made multiple phone calls in here
there's never been a founded case and so
we can we think what you're doing at
this point is knowingly making false
statements and I think that's what I'm
fearful of is that people will start to
hesitate as they see accumulated data if
nothing's happening that could be the
fourth or fifth or sixth call and we we
have seen this on multiple occasions you
know I mean
people call in things don't happen
people don't and then finally the
child's arm is broken or something
happens along those lines and if your
first first thought is I'm going to get
into trouble
you're going to hesitate your first
thought should be under our law
I got to protect this kid and so again
that's where I'm fearful that with the
public not understowing what knowingly
false statement means you may have
people hesitating to protect a child and
then what's the cost of that and that
takes us back to the balancing what is
the cost of doing nothing what is the
cost of doing something along these
lines which may deter people on one end
for making false statements but also May
deter people from calling in
that's not my decision to make that's
your decision to make as a committee I
just want to make you aware of it and I
think particularly the criminal
misdemeanor charges could be very
significant in deterring people from
calling in and and and protecting a
child
to what degree are you familiar with how
much the uh principle of intent is in
play here
knowingly make a false statement would
you expand on intent as perhaps putting
the brakes on rampant run awake uh fear
well in 10 is just such an important
part of criminal law
um you know you can be pulled over by
your car and you don't have to be
intending the speeding and you can get a
ticket that's a part of the law you
don't have to show intent most most
criminal laws there has to be intent to
do something
um and but again I think representative
what I'm going back to is first of all
you're going to be asking the CPS WS to
make a determination or that they
thought that those statements were made
in good faith and then my question comes
back again is if a person is making
multiple reports with good intent but
the pattern looks like they're trying to
harass someone how do you determine that
or not and so that's what I was talking
about the telephone game which is by the
time it would get down to the end here
I'm afraid what people are going to hear
is if you make a false statement you
could be charged with a misdemeanor and
that would cause people to to hesitate
so that that is my concern also you
earlier said you were searching for a
definition of child abuse as it
appertains to this
I thank you for the question I don't
remember saying that okay I'm saying
most people don't know if you stopped
100 people on the street I don't think
the majority of them would know what
abuse and neglect is most people in the
state know that they're mandated
reporters and so the system is set up so
that if you think if in your definition
in your opinion you think abuse and
neglect is happening you call into dcyf
that's what the the point I was trying
to make
okay because it is defined in statute
yes no I'm saying the public I see I
would say that if there are over 10 000
phone calls a year that are made on
abuse and neglect into dcyf the vast
majority of those people probably don't
know what the legal definition of abuse
and neglect is but they think they know
that they're they know their mandated
reporters most people in the state know
this and so they default to calling in
early rather than waiting too long
that that was my point
I don't know if that answered your
question Mr chairman or not I think so
Mr chair I I was going to do a follow-up
with you got ahead of me oh I'm
representative Bickford for a follow-up
our uh researcher has athlete and
quickly pointed out to me that
um 169 C colon 31 immunity for my
ability and it says it it's pursuant to
a good faith report not any report but a
good faith report so my question had
been about knowingly uh false statement
not about the child with a without a
code being reported that's a good faith
report
so the concern of the people brought
this bill for it I would say was
knowingly that somebody is abusing the
system the abuse system and what can
that's it
yeah as I said and I don't thank you for
the question Mr Bickford I I represent
blickford I really do think that people
that are using this law to bludgeon a
spouse or an ex-spouse or
um a neighbor is just completely
incorrect
um I would ask again that the committee
weigh the advantage of people not
hesitating to call in versus people
hesitating to call in afraid they're
going to be charged with the misdemeanor
and that's why I would recommend that if
you're going to go forward with
something like this that you at least
take the misdemeanor part out and you
saying no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you chair calls
Vivian Gerard and she is promising me
two minutes she was up to three at one
point and wonderfully
overs wrote it for two minutes let's see
if you can do it so I was trying to
respect that I appreciate that I'm
talkative too so thank you
um
to the committee for having me up here
again again my name is Vivian Gerard I
actually have a 14 and a 16 year old
daughter so this bill actually
um really says a lot about my case uh
but during my divorce in 2014 the court
ordered a gal
um and the gal actually tried to pull my
children away from me because of a false
police report
Divorced with or without children as
everybody knows is very stressful
anyways uh the gal has many influences
on the future of our children and is
unnecessary in many cases the gal did
not check out any of the evidence in my
case and it didn't even come from any
credible sources change the outcome of
the case when Child Services came out
everything was unfounded and to be
honest with you I agree to a certain
degree with this bill that
representative spleen had put together
but I think it needs some amendments to
it
um I felt that it was very biased and we
did not have equal visits with the gal
no one was looking into the false police
reports the fees that should have gone
into like an account with the Jal they
because the gal knows who's paying a
pers it sways One Direction or the other
with the parent so if the person that's
paying more the other parent is in a
disadvantage we could not speak up until
the case was closed and by then it's too
late you lose your children
um I was accused of child neglect
and an investigation was done in based
on the plant claims from the undisclosed
undisclosed confidential reporter my
case was
um all to avoid child support from my ex
undisclosed individuals can have
profound effects on your case without
the accused ever having the opportunity
to defend against it there is no
consequences or recourse so I'm kind of
glad that this bill is in place the
problem I have is it keeps saying you
may have consequences
um
and the undisclosed person can
essentially give free will to someone to
taint an entire parenting case
and it's usually simply over money
um and to be honest with you
um in my case I was fortunate that I did
not have these outcomes but I did have a
false police report against me I did
have child neglect
complaints against Me based on medical
um because I couldn't afford all the
co-pays to take my child to the doctors
they came in and they did well checks
children could they said because it was
so many the children could it could not
even be left upstairs in their room at
five and seven years old time to bring
it to a close apps absolutely and I I
their jobs then other people would not
be putting in these false claims so if a
mandated reporter actually saw that
there was mental abuse there was child
abuse or anything else these mandators
would probably have more weight on a
false police report or a false report in
general thank you so much will you take
a question or two if there is any I
don't see any so thank you so much okay
again I'm going to
put this out in
good morning Mr chairman good morning
committee thank you for having me I will
try to stick to five minutes nice to see
friendly faces here
I am a mother I'm here to testify in
favor of house bill 108. I am an I.T
professional I deal in IIT but also
process Improvement a mother of three
with autism one has a serious neural
immune condition we are the type of
family that led me to become an advocate
in a state I'm not paid I'm a volunteer
at a little time I have at night I'm on
Facebook and I'm trying to help people
in support groups so I represent an army
of people behind me
um
when you live the life of a family of
children with complex needs and we have
a lot in this state we have kids 36 000
plus with an IEP in the state you find
yourself in the crosshairs of a lot of
different things one is that you start
to struggle right your family struggles
many of us end up in divorce this Brave
young lady behind me I commend her for
her story mine is very similar to that
and what led me here today
there's no place to go for resolution
the courts in the jail didn't care in
our case either and they side with one
party they look at who has the money
it's a very upside down situation and
all of what you think is true that you
go to Great Lengths to document suddenly
turns into a report that's completely
the opposite
and so one side uses the process as a
weapon for us it happened twice in the
case so when I hear things like these
are not good faith reports these people
are making these they know that they
have to be made in good faith I mean
this is stated if anyone reads up on
these kind of complaints they must be
made in good faith so this the the
people that do this that calling these
complaints are often obvious repeated
complaints they are done knowingly to
cause harm
and harass so in our case schools and
neighbors someone who doesn't like you
use it as a weapon for us two or three
times it was that happened to us
um and I'm not here to tell my story
it's really long and I have a book in
the process but um I'm only here to say
that you know other oftentimes last year
we came and we testified in people so
that's a terrible story you know I'm
really sorry that happened to you but I
can tell you I'm not alone again the
Army is behind me and they're all
working hard today and they couldn't be
here but they know about this and
they're behind it
um these are examples of families that
are the most at risk the people who need
our intelligent care and support the
most like mine when you inform the
school nurse after months about your
child getting a surgery that was
discussed with the IEP team and they
turn around and they get snippy and they
decide to call it in because you inform
them the surgery is next week and the
child be out of school there's an
example right there a completely
malicious complaint
or you're dealing with IEP struggles and
someone decides oh you don't like the
tutor we gave you okay we're going to
call in a complaint your kids look
unkempt no basis right
um you're in a divorce they call in
complaints the ex-girlfriend's nudging
the ex husband to calling it complaint
you know you can get away with this I
have people that are up there in Concord
I'm connected with in our case that's
really the fact
and all of these are unfounded what
meanwhile you're trying to complex
you're trying to deal with what this
lady was saying you're trying to keep
your head above water you're trying to
pay all the bills you're trying to keep
your kids healthy go to school fight the
IEP battles in my case try to keep one
alive and literally sitting in a
hospital room getting a phone call with
my child's near death and they're saying
the school nurse called this in because
you sent an email proactively telling
her your child will be out of school
next week
because she thought she needed medical
records which is not her right to ask
for so you're guilty until you're proven
innocent you're accused of actually
helping your child in many of these
unfounded cases other states that we
talked about have a warning as we know
and that's what this is built upon and
the funding what I'm getting to here is
that why process is important is because
last year we sat here gave the same
testimony commissioner rib shim was here
he was actually seemingly in favor of
this that we need to do something
process Improvement costs nothing
adding more staff isn't going to fix
this
so you know when you look at Family Law
you look at the other things that came
about criminal law you perjure yourself
there's a consequence there is
absolutely no consequence here for this
giant catch-all in a day and age where
we're telling everybody out there to see
something say something people get their
15 minutes of fame or they use it as a
way to hurt each other in a very real
and obvious way these are not the not in
good faith case these are these are
absolutely done and they know what
they're doing when they make those calls
the price that we're paying for this is
is it's actually Priceless so it's the
cases like little Adam little Harmony we
don't have the right process in place to
catch those situations but yet we can
catch people that are actually good
upstanding citizens and put them to the
point where the parent feels like
they're gonna have a heart attack over
the stress they're going through because
they're trying to save a child's life
and then they have this on top of that
that is why I'm here and so as far as
people saying it's not my decision to
make you know we don't we worry about
missing somebody there are processes
there are laws in place today for that
um these are people that don't care they
don't care about the law they're doing
it regardless and they're going to do it
whether in Family Court they could be
guilty of perjury they're still going to
do it so there needs to be some teeth
and that's what I'm asking for you to do
is put some teeth out there and don't
make this one big catch-all because the
process is not going to correct that
it's going to hurt people like us people
behind me and the harmonies and the
other kids get missed all the time and
I'm representing this as a child of a
caseworker so I know a little bit of
what I'm talking about I know about
process and I know we can make this
representative petrigno
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question certainly if I heard
your testimony correctly I think I heard
you say that schools and neighbors use
it as a weapon and I think you made
reference to a nurse using um this as to
make malicious complaints absolutely
um I'd like to know if this you think is
a a pattern something that happens
frequently and if you think that nurses
as medical professionals are seeing it
that they're doing their due diligence
thank you it's a good question it's
complex and it varies case to case I
think you know in our case the school
situation was an obvious one
um you know when you are dealing with
children getting an IEP and you're
trying to get supports and services
you're not always the best friend of
everybody on the team and in her case
it's a Personnel issue and that should
have been dealt with by the school I
tried to do that but
they got very angry with me for even
suggesting could have been it was very
obvious the person that it was and
you'll see these things redacted or
blacked out you can tell if you're a
smart enough person by reading the
Records who did it and I do think
there's a pattern with certain people in
her case if I was in charge of her I'd
be looking into has she done this in
other cases there's a fine line you know
where she's crossed between it being
um her her mandatory reporting
responsibility and her being for lack of
I'm sorry for any Karen's in the world
in the room a Karen and she's going up
Way Beyond her scope and she's using it
to hurt somebody
um so I don't know if that hits your
true question but each case can be a
little bit different I do think there
should be mandatory reporters I mean I
consider myself if I look around I've
sat in a parking lot and wondered about
a child who's crying and I sat there and
kind of observed and I thought you know
I don't have all the pieces to this
situation so I'm going to make the right
choice I'm not going to do anything but
you know if I see that again maybe I'll
ask I'll ask a question as a citizen I
talk to the parent you know but I'm not
going to make that jump to conclusions
so I think there's a way it can be done
but um
I don't know if that answers everything
you are looking for any additional
questions
it seems to
um the chairman and vice chairman that
we're not ready to proceed to a vote on
this
um
so we will be adjourning the hearing
and taking it up at a later date
um
we are adjourned to one o'clock
and I might suggest this I gotta run
over next door but it might be a good
time if people would uh like to have
lunch with people you don't know you
know form some uh
interparty bonds and so on but we're
back at one o'clock
welcome to CFL if you think this is the
Canadian Football League you are in the
wrong room this is actually uh What's
this called children and family law and
I opened the hearing on House Bill 151 a
establishing a committee now before I
read any further there is a word that
comes down from the Enchanted Forest
that says Kell they don't like
committees so I suggest that is not the
11th commandment thou shall not
committee but instead it could be a good
vehicle to get
intelligent
ideas floated and policies and so on so
the compromise was Pearson you round up
the people who will be appointed to
these things what they didn't know is I
love it but my little hook on this is
with the consultation of the Bill's
Prime sponsor so together should this
bill ever get signed into law we will
have our people already lined up it's a
deal
good you don't have any choice
establishing a committee to study the
issue of unmarried cohabitants domestic
Partnerships and common law marriage
thank you so much Mr chair and uh it
sounds like this bill's ought to pass I
appreciate that I'm leaving
it's chairman but uh
any objection to it going on consent no
objection Mr chair thank you foreign
thank you in all seriousness
chair Pearson members of the committee I
appreciate your time and attention to
introduce house bill 151.
this is a bill to study the issue of
unmarried cohabitants domestic
Partnerships and common law marriage for
the record I am representative Jim
majori representing Rockingham District
23 the town of Northampton
the bill was this bill the same bill was
introduced by colleagues from the other
body and two in the two previous
legislative sessions in 2020 SB 602
was voted ought to pass from the Senate
Judiciary Committee with a unanimous 6-0
vote it subsequently died a coveted
death in the house in 2022 SB 291
was voted ought to pass in the Senate
Judiciary again with the unanimous 5-0
vote that year the vote out of the house
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee was inexpedient to legislate
by a 12-8 vote the bill died in the
house on the floor by a vote of 179 to
143. one of the reasons I for the itl
might have been as the chair has just
said a caution against a multitude of
study committees and I certainly respect
the uh the continued caution on study
committees and therefore I say Mr chair
members of this committee that the
co-sponsors on this bill Representatives
Murray Balboni as well as Senator Waters
and I are already willing and able to
commit to the work of completing the
study of this issue should we be
appointed and I do know that all the
representatives and Senators that I've
named have said they are willing to go
do the work we might need to find a
Republican or two as well
duly noted
duly noted so I am asking for not to
pass on this bill the majority of U.S
states draw a sharp legal line between
cohabitation and marriage attaching
clear and important rights benefits and
responsibilities to the latter but few
if any to the former
common law marriage is formally
recognized in just eight states Colorado
Iowa Kansas Montana South Carolina Texas
Utah end our great state of New
Hampshire a common law marriage is a
legally recognized Union between two
people who have not purchased a marriage
license or had their marriage solemnized
by a ceremony
domestic Partnerships recognize the
union of two people but differ from a
common law marriage in that the domestic
partnership is a union moving forward
effective from this day for instance
while a common law marriage is more
commonly retroactive we recognize the
partnership as a result of time
unmarried cohabitants live under the
same roof
there is a common law marriage exception
in New Hampshire under RSA Force excuse
me 457 colon 39 which gives a spouse
share of the estate of a deceased common
law spouse but for the exception to be
valid the couple must cohabitate
that is live under the same roof for and
acknowledge each other as husband and
wife for a period of three years that's
an important distinction you will hear
testimony today the devastation that can
occur when a couple is for all intents
and purpose in a common law marriage yet
gaps and silence in state law render
surviving members of the relationship
helpless in the wake of life-changing
events if two people are in a committed
relationship they might be expected to
contract
this is some of the argument that was
made in the last session
a legal marriage creates a reciprocal
contract between spouses including
benefits of an estate and
responsibilities for care upon death and
we commonly call this type of contract a
will
in a recent Gallup poll oh my nose is
running can I borrow tissue for a second
sorry about that
for health reasons it has to be a gift
Okay I accept the gift
in a recent Gallup poll only 46 percent
of married couples have a will
results have been similar in three other
polls on the same question since 1990.
we cannot assume all the reasons why a
couple will not create a will but we can
be sure that committed couples both
married and those unmarried and domestic
Partnerships and common law marriages
may put themselves at some risk
a study published by the Pew Research
Center discovered that more adults in
our country are delaying or even
foregoing marriage altogether between
1995 and the time of the study in 2019
the share of adults who were legally
married declined slightly from 58
percent to 53 percent
yet over that same period the share of
adults who were living in an unmarried
excuse me living with an unmarried
partner more than doubled rising from
three percent to seven percent
according to U.S census data the U.S
marriage rate hit an all-time low in
that same year of 2019. for every one
thousand unmarried adults in 2019 only
33 got married this number was 35 in
2020 excuse me 2010 and 86 in 1970 this
decline in marriages and rise in
cohabitation might pull us into a
conversation about morality and the
sanctity of marriage it is very possible
the lack of law Nationwide on this
matter relates to a principled view that
marriage creates stability
it is possible that legislators
Nationwide May hold that common law
marriages and domestic Partnerships are
potentially unstable and susceptible to
fraud
but it is interesting that cohabitation
is more likely to function as a
substitute for being single
not being married and therefore more a
function of a loving commitment than
rather devoid of it
the testimony following mind will
demonstrate the cohabitation common law
marriages and domestic Partnerships can
join two very committed people in a
loving stable relationship those
relationships May produce equally
committed loving families there are laws
that protect children born into common
law marriages
I this study May explore those laws but
the focus of the study is more likely to
step to Center on the rights and
responsibilities of the of adults that's
a supposition on my on my behalf for
instance what happens when one of the
people in those committed relationship
dies prior to producing a contract and
there is no next of kin or the next of
kin are estranged
if assets are legalized under a business
from the deceased does the surviving
member have rights and responsibilities
for the benefits or dissolution of the
business
what happens if the Australian members
of the deceased fail to assume the
responsibilities for the disposition of
the deceaseds body
the study will examine the rights and
responsibilities of people in those
relationships who experience a multitude
of very regular common and often tragic
events for which our state law is either
silent or where there are gaps I thank
you very much for your time and
attention and of course I submit to
questions
you have a copy of your written
testimony for our files Mr chair I have
and I have submitted it to the clerk
representative Bickford
thank you Mr Jerry I just can't resist
um were you trying to go with this I
wasn't really clear on that on where
we're headed you know
you're trying to get people married uh
sorry about that you know
you you uh somebody that creates
marriage parties or
no sorry I thank you for the question
representative and where we're trying to
go when this was this issue was first
brought to my attention and you'll hear
testimony from the person who did that
it it presented the what ifs to the
legal side of this by the way I have no
I I my my I do not get people married I
I have no business in that whatsoever
this is a constituent that brought this
up when I entered this room I heard from
somebody who had the polar opposite
uh circumstances in their life where
they were actually considered
cohabitating but the law created such
problem there was gray area in the law
such that it created legal problems
we're looking at this from the legal
side of where do people stand now I I
won't suppose that I know how exactly to
do that yet but we're going to bring in
whatever parties are necessary to help
us find that gray area and close any
gaps in the law so that we can both
protect people who are well not both but
we can protect people who are in these
kind of relationships
you
I I feel you should have brought those
fall with those issues or problems that
you
want solved
but due respect I think you'll hear that
in the testimony that follows okay sure
thank you
your advocacy is to set up a study
commission and you're you're giving a
big overall view of the picture not
necessarily making any recommendations
is that your purpose correct
and and Mr chair
um
uh and I know words are important I
think but would certainly welcome the
the recommendations of the committee of
this committee that a committee might be
better simply because it is smaller and
we might have a better chance of being
able to bring in the professionals uh
who can help us with that if this
committee thinks that a larger
commission is the better route I'm open
to the wisdom of the folks we don't
I I yield not because of the quality of
the people here but because a working
group that can be mobile I know from
experience can get a lot more done a lot
quicker than recommendations can come
back
thank you not because we're not quality
here
thank you so much for your testimony
chair recognizes for three minutes
Vivian Gerard three minutes she's proven
there we go well done sorry
um thank you my name is Vivian Gerard
and I I'm the owner of Timber post bed
and breakfast and as many of you heard
prior I've been dealing with a really
bad nine-year divorce so I'm very very
against marriages or the government
getting involved in my life they've
proven that they've done nothing but
caused damage and left damage behind so
first I know that you had
a chair that you had said that you'd
like some recommendations and I actually
have some along the way that can be
handed over to this committee that's
going to be established perfect because
I could be that rep that Republican that
could be on the study if you'd like
anyways
um part of this is
um if somebody was going to get married
automatically they go in and apply for a
marriage license wouldn't it be kinda a
great idea if somebody had an auntie
enough where before you get put in the
situation education of divorce you
already walk in there knowing okay I'm
bringing this to the table if something
happens I'm taking that back with me or
as they get further in their Journey
they can add different things and they
should go into this as a business
contract
so when you're working with property or
whatever the case may be kids at least
it's talked about when you're
level-headed and not when it becomes a
big contested divorce
so
everyone
um as I said should should be that goes
in for a marriage license should be
forced to take a pre-marriage class so
you know as any other contract you know
what you're going into this contract
what you could lose and what can change
the way life is now
um they don't communicate
the the parts of divorce that will
affect your life in this way
and the government's role is to help
protect parties with the Health and
Welfare not to really sit there and
divide their assets up of unmarried
parties may I suggest we're getting
somewhat off topic this sounds like an
opening Salvo for the committee when it
meets we are here to speak to the merits
or not merits of establishing a
committee well and so can you make that
point so so the point that I'm trying to
make is being somebody of divorce I know
what is affected personally in in my
experience so having this study
certainly helps bring other parts of
this to
the government here and if somebody has
a single status they should be able to
remain single and one last thing that I
want to touch upon
um in in my experience because I do rent
out rooms in my situation
I lost alimony by having a renter and
even though I had a rental agreement the
judge waived the role and decided that
she was going to make up her own
decision on it so whether I you have
somebody in three years living with you
you might enter into a contract that you
don't even know that you've entered a
contract into we've hit our time okay
and one last thing that I'd like to um
leave you with is you know having the
three-year window and they they talk
about it being a lover a friend a
roommate or whatever the case may be
with everything changing from Man Woman
now it's changing to persons to be legit
um in my case because of renting out
this
cohabitation Bill the RSA
could certainly harm people like me or
not even have protection of a for the
deceased thank you will you take a
question absolutely question
I don't see a question so thank you so
much okay now
Spanish is fungilio
Italian is fungillo
uh I don't recall this in when I lived
in England so Beth would you come up
we are multilingual in this committee
here
um
Mr chair with with your permission may I
join uh Miss franzilio up here for moral
support it is apparent to have done so
yes back to my seat at your suggestion
uh well we do have time but I'll waive
that thank you and you are Beth Angelo
fungelio
for today in brief I'm here
at the story of two people who lived Our
Lives as husband and wife
on October 27th of 2021 I got a phone
call that Mark had gone into cardiac
arrest in my driveway
upon arriving to the hospital I was told
that he was on life support and they
needed to take him off and it was my
decision to do so would I please come in
the bathroom and do that I did
in the meantime I called his two
estranged brothers so he hadn't seen in
well over 10 years or spoken with very
much except for when his mom got cancer
in 2018.
the two of them showed up after I spent
some time with the medical examiner
about 30 minutes answering questions
about Mark's life in our life together
once those Brothers showed up I no
longer had rights the medical examiner
turned his back to me he only addressed
those brothers who came out of the
woodwork and I could make no further
decisions for Mark
they were asked what Mark's final wishes
were and they had to let them know he
wished to be cremated
they didn't know they didn't have an
answer for him they were asked is he an
organ donor they said I don't know and
our friend a priest who was with me said
yes he is and we have his license to
show it
the medical examiner continued to
address these two brothers who hadn't
been around in all these years and knew
nothing and I know longer mattered
so from there we left we went back into
the room spent some time with Mark the
brothers left our friend who's a priest
spent some time with Mark and we left
the hospital
that night I got a phone call from the
Oregon bank that the brothers had signed
his body over to me they wanted no part
of his organ donation or his burial
so from there I took care of the organ
donation I called their brother his
brother in the morning and said I need
to go to the funeral home would one of
you be willing to come with me they said
no
upon arriving to the funeral home I was
told because we weren't married I really
didn't have a right to bury him if he
has next of kin I have no rights so
after a long talk with the funeral home
he was able to come up with a law that
covered abandonment and estrangement to
allow me to give him a proper burial
from near ASAP Council because I didn't
know what to do what are my rights we
aren't married and do these brothers
have rights to everything and apparently
they did our businesses our bed our
everything had to be turned over
and so I asked if we can have this
conversation can we find those great
areas because I don't believe I'm alone
I'm an assistant town clerk for the town
of Hampton and I can tell you two
stories of exactly what happened to me
happened to others one was a 25 year old
girl driving to New Jersey to get
married
and her fiancee was killed in the car
with her and her baby her and her baby
came in our office to register a car and
she couldn't because his name was on the
title she didn't even have a right in
the state of New Hampshire to get a
death certificate she's the mother of
his child and she can't get a death
certificate in the state of New
Hampshire
there are far too many of these stories
far too many that I think we at least
should have the conversation
let's find those bright areas and let's
help people because I'm not alone and I
don't think it's right so I ask you
today please to support this Committee
in going forward
thank you for your time
and thank you so much for your sharing
your story with us we appreciate that
you're right it is more common than one
would think
close to hearing on House Bill 151 and
with the agreement of ranking member I
open an exec session on the same bill
remember the bill before us
is not to make any determinations about
changing laws to build before us is to
set up a study committee that will bring
forward recommendations which at a
future date will probably be lsrs that
some of us turn in that is what is
before us to establish a study committee
what is your motion representative
Bickford
motion Dives for lack of a second is
there another motion
representative long
thank you Mr Mr chairman I'll I'll move
uh OTP is there a second
is your microphone answer
I feel there are bright lines I'm very
familiar with the subject at hand
um you either I'm married or not married
the only thing I've seen uh that would
be questionable is a common law marriage
which doesn't happen until after you're
dead
after you're dead someone can make a
claim that they
uh lied about your situation
and claimed that they were married to
you and then they can go after your
estate I think that's wrong
that that's the only thing I can see
that needs to be changed
um otherwise the situations uh like the
lady that spoke to us
um
you could be dating someone and claim
well
you know this is my person that I want
to take care of but
you have to have uh agreements between
I take
to to try and make some kind of changes
I
um there's just too many of us in this
world that want freedom and that my
concern is
having people try to stuff
uh marriage down our throats
um
I know it's kind of strong language
but uh
I'm not married I've never been married
and I've been with the same woman 35
years so I'm more successful than most
people that have been married
and we don't want to be married
we like what the agreements that we've
made we don't want to go to court like
Miss
Gerard we want to stay out of it
and we can do that with our agreements
so that's why I'm
I'm posed because of the direction I
believe this is trying to go in
I believe this is necessary to be honest
especially in a lot of communities this
is common common to leave without being
married
but a lot of times
there's no paper saying that you've been
living with this person for so many
years and then you have the same rights
as someone is married and then you can
and I believe this committee will help
a lot of us to understand the
consequences of you know the issue that
uh the test
the person who testified just brought up
to our attention it happens a lot and I
see it happen a lot and especially
um
in
underrepresented communities
and that's why I think it's critical for
us to have a study committee on this
thank you thank you representative
anyone else wish to speak representative
Greg
um unless I'm mistaken I don't think
this is trying to shove marriage down
people's roads I think it's trying to
protect people who have also chosen not
to get married it's a conversation
um you know that I've heard a lot
especially in the times the health
concerns that we've had the last few
years that have you know seen younger
people and you know do we have to be
married to have this and and certainly
you know for this last woman that
testified it compounded her entire grief
situation when family was able to come
in and a lot of times we do have family
estrangement
um you know I I think it's more actually
protecting a situation like yours you
know where you haven't been married for
but you've been together 35 years that
that Union and what you guys have built
should be producted and it shouldn't
have to be on
um so I think a study figuring out
exactly is there a need here because
we've now heard you know at least one
case where
thank you representative anyone else
wish to speak representative panic
so the way that I'm just looking for
some clarification so the way the laws
are written now if you're cohabitating
um or you're in a common law marriage
that if you had your partner pass on and
then strange family member can come and
take away your house your car is that
we actually don't ask that question I
don't know who I'm supposed to be asking
the question to I'm asking you anybody
in the committee who might know yeah
representative Bickford do you know well
that's that's your property I mean it's
your house
um we own a house together her name on
it my name's on it then you make a
decision whether it's going to be in
common or uh or survivorship
um like they all will will give you your
rights you don't need anything this
you don't want somebody I would want to
say it
um if you want to be married you can be
married there's nothing says you can't
be married that's what gets me
go ahead and get married and that then
these problems that you think are going
to happen to you are not going to happen
to you
but I own like I say a lot of property
of my own and then we own property
together
with both our names on the property and
you'll do that even if you're married
you'll see it on there but there's
throughout Homestead rights that go to
married people but we're all aware of
those things you know we work with
lawyers and we know what our rights are
we actually do have rights
as single people
so this is almost like a prenuptial
agreement oh I'm sorry it's different
we
representative D Simone please thank you
Mr chair I have a question of the chair
if you have access to the common law
marriage statute
and I don't see my committee researcher
there do I can take this testimony from
someone in the audience if you have that
what was the question I didn't I may Mr
chair I just have to go through that's
fine I will come back to that question
I apologize for the time spent this
talks about cohabitation not common law
marriage
it doesn't answer your question
particularly I believe that's where it
why don't we give you a few minutes to
continue to read on and we'll see if
there's anybody else who would like to
say anything representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman
um so there is no
um common law Statute in New Hampshire
um if you did a search in the New
Hampshire rsas you wouldn't find common
law the only thing that's referred to as
cohabitation
um So currently in New Hampshire since
um you have to be married in order to
get that automatic death benefit if
you're just cohabitating and you don't
have a will or a property in both
parties names it doesn't go to the other
the surviving party so when we have
people who are living together in a
committed relationship whether they have
children or not
they are considered two single people
residing in the same home they are not
considered to be a couple in any legal
way in New Hampshire
children allows for property to transfer
to the children but not to the parent of
that child without any other will or
legal proceeding
um so at this point I don't think that
this study is asking us to pass any
bills to do any of that to me it sounds
like the study is to see who like what's
the commonality of
um or how common is this practice in New
Hampshire and is there a need for any
legislation to address it and I don't
think we can address the question of
whether or not legislation is needed
unless we study the issue so for myself
I am in favor of studying the issue
seeing what the committee comes back
with and then at that point
discussing through public hearing and
and through executive session whether or
not any legislation is warranted
thank you representative representative
DeSimone did you find something
thank you Mr chair I did and I found
what I thought I would find because I I
was under the impression that New
Hampshire does not have uh and does not
recognize common law marriage uh except
extended to the cohabitation issue
um and and that's what I thought and I
don't want to make a
I don't want to vote based on a thought
I just wanted to have the actual proof
so in this it discusses
um common law marriage there is no such
thing or a statute in the state of New
Hampshire
um so I thank you for indulging me
so so do you think a study of this would
be helpful
or warranted at least
considering the fact that
um
people should be
more
um in tune with the consequences of the
decision-making process
and the fact that they should seek legal
advice before they jump into something
like this
um I I'm not really in favor of another
commission
okay
then representative Bickford you may
have another bite at the Apple
oh
it's mine now proud Grossman I was
delayed thank you chairman
um just a thought that comes to mind in
order to have a will and to have these
legal pieces in place if you're not
married you have to have access
you have to have money you have to have
money to get these legal services that
will put things into place for you
um so just want to throw that thought
out there that it affects maybe
potentially couples that don't have
access to that
I seem to understand or remember at
least that on many agreements two
parties can do it and have it notarized
and this has been in place for a long
time because of the very effect that was
mentioned that many people especially
young couples do not have the money for
lawyers
anyone else with anything
yes I just wanted to add that there is
such a thing it was we've seen as
prenuptial we have the anti-nutuals in
Supreme Court said that they have a
higher standing than a contract we often
hear I often hear people talk about
contracts
um you know the common law thing is we
call it it isn't there's a lot of case
law on it which I've looked at
extensively
so I um I do want to point that out and
the cost of a lawyer it's a lot cheaper
to go to lawyer before you make a
mistake than it is active
you have to get a divorce lawyer
[Music]
no
um and one last thing is
I'm concerned that we're
that we're doing
these execs without looking at what
people have sent us remotely as you
recall I was looking to try to get in so
I could find because the remote gets cut
off at noon time so people are sending
us information from outside and yeah we
may never have looked at it I would say
it's important to us
the motion before us to establish a
committee to study the issue of
unmarried cohabitants domestic
Partnerships and common law marriage the
motion is ought to pass made by
representative long and seconded by
representative Perez would the clerk
representative DeSimone
no
representative Nelson
Bickford
Mike on and yes or no
no
representative Nelson
representative
ball
no
representative panic
representative Seidel
no
representative Grossman
yes
representative Levesque
representative Perez
yes
representative Greg
representative Petrino the clerk votes
yes
has everyone been called I believe so
McMahon was called No McMahon I
apologize all right I'll vote Yes
foreign
missing and representative Pearson
um
both CS primarily because it's just a
study committee so the vote is nine yes
six no the motion passes
ought to pass
and who will write the committee report
which is the majority report
representative long is pointing to
someone oh representative Lauren is
volunteered okay
okay
and someone may wish to write The
Minority Report that is nothing the
chair organizes because the chair
organizes the committee which is the
majority so one of you who wishes to uh
who voted no wishes to write The
Minority Report
just hand that report to me you'll have
to discuss it amongst yourselves we have
a four minute break coming up and both
reports I will need to have by
um they're going to be talking amongst
themselves during the break this ends
the uh the exec committee on house uh
executive session on House Bill 151 and
we have a four-minute recess before the
next bill with the six people who voted
no caucus amongst yourselves and one of
you let me know you're writing The
Peter yeah up the uh Forum Community
report
s
what Deputy Simone please come to the
front
not with reluctance we love a cheerful
Giver
thank you very much
open the hearing on House Bill 218 FN
relative to court rules and transcripts
in the judicial branch Family Division
representative J.D Bernardi Prime
sponsor
thank you Mr chairman and and committee
I'm JD Bernardi Rockingham 36 which is
Hampton Falls Kensington Newton plastow
and Southampton I am from Southampton I
am on the Science Tech and energy
committee which is also a meeting right
now so I'm dispatched for this purpose
uh as a sponsor of 218 I would like to
point out that basically the bill
addresses three problems one is the
waiver of court rules two is the ability
to create recordings and transcripts and
three is the ability to use those
recordings and transcripts in the
Appellate Procedure
now turning first to the waiver of rules
what are we talking about this is rules
regarding courtroom conduct Rules of
Evidence pleadings testimonies
representation Discovery depositions
interrogatories appeals there there are
over 50 pages of rules and I've given
you a handout the very first page is an
extract from the rules and I want to
point you to rule 1.2 which is
for the record it's what looks like this
it's it's this it's this document where
it has the squiggle in between 1.2 and
2. uh 2.2 which indicates there's a lot
of rules in between and
um
so 1.2 basically allows the court
to basically disregard or wave family
court rules
2.2 allows the court to waive All the
Rules of Evidence of the New Hampshire
so imagine you're going to court for the
first time you're dealing with a court
uh a a court issue and all the rules
are pulled out from underneath you the
rug is gone you are going to hear
several people testify behind me of the
specifics of this of this problem but
indeed it is a problem it does exist and
it's only fair
we believe that we set court rules we
have them for all the other courts in
the in the state and we follow those
rules
and they may be waived as as the
218 uh provides here with respect to
fees in your executive session you may
say uh maybe they have to be waived for
some other specific purpose if you do
that I my only comment is
identify a very specific reason why a
rule may be waived otherwise this
General waiver which exists in 1.2 and
2.2 is an anathema to the judicial
process
with respect to recordings and
transcripts the next several pages of
that handout deal with this issue the
first is a request for proposal from the
court system
for digital auto
recording systems and I want to point
you uh to page three number at the
bottom uh where
um
it is going over the business
requirements of the scope of work of
this digital system the very last item
item I in the middle of the page says
software must be compatible with touch
screen kiosk mode which would allow for
Standalone use of audio recording
functions and features
so this this is basically asking for a
system where we do not need court
reporters we do not need any other
function areas in the room we can just
have the bailiff or the judge or whoever
manage this system and it's all done
digitally
in the in principle nothing wrong with
that
however
you look at the next uh series of pages
this is a the request for proposal
vendor uh questions to the to the court
what is it that you want and I ask you
to look at uh their response to 2A
which is found on the very next page
after the RFP
um and it says if not reporter deck what
are the hardware requirements of the
touch screen kiosk
mode device answer all in one uh Dell PC
running Windows 10 with kiosk deep
freeze by vary onyx
software installed this is for the
courtroom that
that do not have a court room monitor
Court assistant clerk to run their
queries instead to have only a bailiff
to start and stop the recording so this
could be the bailiff or it could be the
judge or it could be someone else but a
single a single person dealing with this
then I ask you to look at item 16 which
is on the second fill is on the last
page the first the uh the front part of
the first page
um
as a summary of our questions this
procedure appears more related to
Services as opposed to software
licensing there are Cloud transcriptions
or even interpretive services that
appear to be part of the procurement if
this is the case please State this and
we will make our decision uh to respond
based upon the true nature of the uh
procurement
I go to the bottom of the answer it says
the goal is no is to have no long is is
to no longer have court staff manually
upload the annual and audio recordings
to the transcription service provider
and the manual transcription back backup
recordings to CD and have an automated
process for the court to receive its
portions of the funds collected by the
transcription service
the last page the back is a
it is just a simple ad
um and I point you to the right hand
side the FTR gold player and the third
criteria the audio Channel
uh isolation and foot pedal control
so
this is a device that can be used in
this recording system such that
a foot pedal can control when the
recording is on and when the recording
is off and it can be done by one person
could be done by the bailiff could be
done by the judge could be done by
whoever is close to that foot pedal
now why is that an issue and why are we
asking for
um
recordings and transcripts
as you are going to hear from various
parties to judicial proceedings where
the transcripts and recordings do not
contain the full information that
happened in those hearings
information adverse to the court or
adverse to one party has been deleted
and the consequences are significant for
the other party
so this bill
simply gives all parties the opportunity
to make recordings and transcripts
and then if they're going to be used in
any Appellate Procedure I have to point
out where they differ from the official
recording and transcript
of the court and they can carry on their
case effectively
so I ask you to listen to the the
testimony of those that have been
adversely impacted by court records that
do not reflect what actually happened in
the court and considered that this is a
option A very simple opportunity to for
those litigants to remedy that situation
representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman um
and thank you for coming to bring this
to us today
um I have
um three questions and uh one is kind of
background information and the other two
are specifically regarding your proposal
here
um and the first one is under the
current system
if an individual a party in one of these
Court proceedings feels that the
official record does not reflect what
actually happened what is the current uh
recourse that that individual is able to
take
they they only can bring their
their case I mean what they they don't
have any evidence they don't have a
recording because they're they were not
allowed to take a recording uh and so
they can they can make their statements
and they can have witnesses if there
were any other members of in in that
hearing that were there but generally
audiences that are very constrained so
so the opportunity is generally very
limited so generally they're out of luck
okay and then if I can follow up thank
you and then the other questions I had
um are regarding
um the part of your proposal that would
allow individuals to take their own
audio or woman to some video as well
recordings in these not video videos not
allowed in the courts okay that's what I
curious whether or not you wanted to
allow that so their own audio recorder
record um the the first part of the
question is
um how does your bill or how could your
bill provide a chain of custody so that
there is not the possibility of any
tampering with those audio recordings
and this second part of the question is
how can this bill ensure the continued
confidentiality of children's both
identities and disclosures during family
core proceedings
so the first part is a chain of custody
of the recording right how how can
how assured that these recordings that
um lay people who are involved in these
processes have not been edited or
altered or changed in any way or that
they've remained in the possession of
the only the person who was in the room
and then the second part is regarding
children's confidentiality for both
their identity and any disclosures they
might make while they're testifying
foreign
so the chain of custody question is is
interesting I I mean I think normally
that the reason you have a recording is
because and and what you'll you'll hear
testimony about is in the in the
Court reportings where things have been
removed you'll hear a click of the
recording going off and I click when it
goes back on again
so in a recording where that is does not
happen you're not going to hear that no
uh
I I don't know if that is going to be
adequate evidence I mean this is
something that the that the Appellate
Court is going to basically have to
address
as to whether they believe the Integrity
the questions for the representatives
well excuse me Mr chairman She also
uh children's identity
um
can I restate your question
representative Raymond Raymond thank you
yes so the the second part of the
question is currently children who are
involved in Family Court proceedings
um have a right to privacy their
identities and any disclosures that they
make on the stand is not accessible to
the public and it's required even if you
look at the you know the court cases are
they're not identified by name they're
identified by initial to protect their
privacy so how would your bill ensure
that lay people coming in and making
their own recordings are not able to
release that information to the public
and maintain the privacy of children who
may or may not be victims
so you're saying
the presumption of your question if I
get it right is that this recording
that's done in in the hearing would be
released to the public as as and a court
record would not be and and hence
there's going to be some disclosure of
of the Privacy Information how does one
prevent that yes
I in principle one one can't however I
do not believe that that is normally the
the circumstance uh that's that's being
addressed here normally
um
children are not allowed into the into
the hearings when most times
because they're not allowed to be
Witnesses
it it doesn't strike me as a reasonable
activity that someone would want to take
this recording and then take it to the
press the purpose is to document the
records of the in an Appellate Procedure
you you can truly
um make your case for what happened in
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question relates
to lines 13 and 14 where it says the
Appellate Court shall review the
differences in recordings and Associated
transcripts and so on
um
who what uh what level of person or what
job in the Appellate Court
whose job would it be to review those
differences
I'm sorry my assumption it's going to be
who's ever sitting on the bench on that
on that day I mean they're looking at
whoever's looking at evidence this is
just another piece of evidence just like
any other piece of evidence
um
follow-up
representative Greg
Greg thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um so I just I guess I have a question
when the court is recording right now
there is no
law that's requiring them to record like
a certain amount or anything like to say
this entire thing has to be recorded so
there's nothing right now holding the
courts who would be an official
recording to record the entire thing
well they have to record the entire
thing in principle in order to make a
transcript of what's what happened in
the court
if if a judge is not behaving
appropriately and that's generally
what's going on here
and they want to
um
make some comments that they don't find
very acceptable to be on that transcript
the button is pushed the transcript
stops the comments are made that are
adverse to a party or or adverse to the
judge if it was heard and then the
button is pushed and and the recording
goes on so that's what we're trying to
protect against we're trying to stop or
can I follow it
would it be more prudent than to have a
law that would require
that the judges because I I worry about
having a bunch of different people for
the reason of um and I have seen quite a
few cases where children testify
especially in the family courts
um you know worried about their privacy
would it would it not make more sense to
have something that would instead of you
know letting people kind of you know
record at will or whatever in there and
a bunch of different people
um to require the courts to have the
entire thing recorded because you know
start time and time and so you'd able to
know if anything had been redacted or
anything would that make more sense
if you had faith that that was going to
actually happen that's fine but you I we
started off this uh discussion with the
rules
the rule 1.2 we we just we can waive any
rule of the Family Court rule 2.2 we can
rule All the Rules of Evidence they're
just suggestions so
that's part of the problem here is is
what is reasonable judicial conduct is
thank you representative Bernardi
and we will dismiss you from further
speaking but not until we first hear
from representative Bickford
thank you Mr I'm sorry I may miss part
of what you said but the gist of it I
think is you want you look for a backup
system aren't you so essentially looking
for a backup for basically people to
prove that the the court system has
behaved inappropriately and we have if
you look back in our records recently we
have a lot of problems in the family
court I mean I I may just make a
statement here I I I'm on the Science
Tech and energy committee I'm an
engineer and pharmacist and and did drug
development uh and and so this is not my
area of expertise
but I ran to be a representative for the
people of New Hampshire
and
my constituents are saying we have got a
major problem in the family court
constituent at the constituent
a problem
we're being mistreated and the evidence
is being hid
now there are cases where this has come
out
but it's an ongoing problem
that is the fundamental
underpinning of why this legislation is
we've got some people who want to
testify and uh got a couple of folks who
promised to be brief I'm going to hold
it to you and please make sure you are
actually addressing the bill before us
and for three minutes she asks Katrina
Heinrich
foreign
thank you Mr chairman committee my name
is Katrina Heinrich and I am in support
of HB 218 FN
I support it relative to the court rules
and transcripts in the judicial Family
Division
in my experience in over a decade of
Court litigation of fabricated orders
this bill addresses three of the most
egregious and significant problems that
are consistent across comparable cases
the family court acts like a business
instead of a court of law by emitting
due process
creating unnecessary financial hardship
and dismissing the Rules of Evidence
New Hampshire rule 2.2 as the esteemed
representative just pointed out
that's the Rules of Evidence they do not
um
forever decade
I have personally been citing zero due
process in my case as they were churning
out fabricated orders
court orders are anchored in fabricated
fantasy yet over a decade the orders
have unnecessarily protracted the case
intentionally involved third-party
private contractors that were
unwarranted and damaged and harmed my
children and myself
the court orders are not based in
reality or fact and therefore are
artificially manufactured to achieve a
specific agenda
these orders without evidence violate
due process but even more egregiously
carry the weight of consequences
lifelong life-altering consequences for
those that are being victimized by the
court process and the resulting orders
usually the non-offending litigant and
children
the second and the third thing I want to
address is the court transcripts cost
and recording accuracy
transcripts are the only source for
litigants to appeal fabricated orders
written transcripts are Beyond
reasonable for the typical litigant with
a hefty fee schedule
transcript accuracy is at the discretion
of the Court
transcripts have testimony
and courtroom behaviors missing without
proper law citation or justification for
the missing testimony and room behaviors
transcripts missing testimony and
courtroom behaviors typically show a
large segment of time
missing with an accompanying word of
pause
this indicates that the live recording
is being stopped and started during the
court process
therefore not an accurate and true
accounting of the Court
I do have an example that I attended
another
another person's hearing
and this happened to be with judge Foley
who happens to have a standing computer
desk you can see his hands his feet the
entire process
during the hearing judge Foley tapped
the foot pedal and the keyboard area he
proceeded to verbally bully and belittle
the litigant when the litigant was
finally able to get a copy of the
transcript the pause segment intact had
been activated and the entire court
Behavior was missing
with over a decade of myself
being forced in the Family Court my
examples of missing testimony began as
early as 2007 in an assault trial prior
to my divorce
with this brief summary of experiences
House Bill 218 not only addresses these
distinctive issues addresses a lack of
due process the organization of a
business entity
that engages in third party associations
with private contracted Guardian ad
litems therapists transcription
companies collabority
forcing litigants into protected cases
financial distress void of due process
and I know the representative gave you
the request for proposals paper
and I'll again close by referring to
the last sentence on number 16.
and really the last part of that
sentence which is they want an automated
process for the court to receive its
portion of funding collected by the
transcription service
so funding
and inaccurate reporting seems to be the
thank you for your testimony do we have
I see none thank you for your testimony
I do have copies
and the chair recognizes Vivian Gerard
again three minutes she asks thank you
foreign
thank you chairman and members of the
board as many of you know my name is
Vivian Gerard I've been in this um
here testifying today and I'd like to
take the transcripts separate then the
court rules and I'll and I'll you'll see
where I'm going with that so as I had
mentioned I am self-employed
and as Katrina had mentioned to you the
cost of audio when you're going through
a court battle is 25
per CD I had 27 herons and nine to the
Supreme Court we rely on the transcripts
to be correct
the outcome of your case is heavily
heavily viewed based on those
transcripts and what I want to bring to
your attention on the handouts that I'm
going to be given to you is I have a
Judicial conduct committee that shows
how much stuff was changed based on the
judge the judge can do whatever they
want they do have a button that they can
turn on and off and it took many many
transcripts for me to show that I was
bullied by these judges and two of them
got thrown off the bench and one of the
actually there's been a few comments but
one of them specifically is reopening a
can of worms
um it was viewed by the judicial conduct
committee and they heard the Audio I
have all my transcripts all my audios
and there is nothing on any of my
transcripts but I remember hearing it in
court but there was nothing on any of my
documents that showed those
that these comments were missing but
then once it was reviewed by the
judicial conduct committee this judge
was reprimanded for not only just saying
all these condescending items but also
the fact that these were not on the
transcripts The JCC cannot provide me
that audio so that's what I want to talk
about with the transcripts the court
rules
um is another situation
this Finder right here I brought this in
if you guys would like a copy I'd be
more than happy to make you a copy this
is what happens when the judge makes up
her own rules I went to the Supreme
Court and these are all the rules that
the judge
deviated without any reason there was
she did not have any good
uh written information for me as to why
she changed her mind and one
specifically is the child support which
I created this
the state law and she said my kids did
not deserve child support so why is she
changing the rule which was the law
which I created why is she changing this
rule saying that I don't deserve it when
the Supreme Court keeps remanding it
back to the local Court you have
I'm pretty much done but I just want you
to know that no matter what happens the
judge can make up anything that they
want and this is true evidence of what
they do
I I'm sorry very very briefly how much
is it for the chair recognizes
representative Raymond thank you
chairman how much did you say it was for
one CD of your hearing so one CD is 25
that's for an audio CD that's not the
written transcript so when you go to the
Supreme Court they request a written
transcript but in order to make sure
that they're correct you're going to
listen to the audio and follow along
with the transcript
follow-up one follow-up do you also have
to pay for the transcript yes and how
much is that
um
so one thousand seven hundred dollars
for two days of testimony
two and uh seeing no further questions
foreign
turn on the mic that's quite all right
good afternoon chairman Pearson
nice to see you and good afternoon Vice
chairman long and honorable members of
the committee my name is Justin Neto and
I'm a lifelong resident of New Hampshire
um
I've worn
just about every hat you can think of
you know attorney
counselor uh professor at UNH for many
years
inventor businessman colleague brother
son
friend even best friend if you can
believe it but no title has more
significance than Daddy
and
and that is the hat that I'm wearing
today
and here is a daddy and as a concerned
citizen
I was raised to believe in our country
just like all of us and our system of
justice and
our system our family court system is
more
more than just fractured it truly is
I when I saw this bill being proposed I
was I was delighted I really was very
very happy to see that this was being
proposed and I was compelled I've never
been before a committee before I've
never testified and this is the first
time there are numerous documented
incidents that over the years I've
served as petitioners Council as
representative respondents council and
sadly I'm in the middle of my own
divorce presently
um
while there's a numerous there are many
many instances I could decide I just
want to just leave you with this uh the
transcripts the recordings are vital
they're crucial to cases
especially when you're dealing with an
appeal one example I can just give you
very briefly is uh you know a judge's
level of judicial in in judicious
conduct
I am lost in a sea of adjectives because
it is beyond description
um and uh
the the Audio I had requested the Audio
I received the auto recording back uh
the judge had a complete
meltdown uh and said some of the most
horrible things I've ever heard and
um had he had the judge had then looked
at the court reporter and said were we
on the record
and she looked at the judge and she said
judge we are on the record
and the judge immediately Departed the
courtroom uh I had requested the audio
and I believe the the other Council
request the audio and the audio abruptly
shuts out shuts off
just prior to the Meltdown
and it's not just that that wasn't
captured within the audio but also
significant substantive issues were
dealt with during that time as well uh
that could have could have been used on
appeal so you know it's not just the
judge's conduct that we're talking about
we're talking also about uh you know
litigants rights and if there is an
issue that has just been put on the
record that there's no longer any record
of it severely jeopardizes the rights of
the party
in closing I believe this bill does have
great Merit
I will ensure it will ensure that the
playing field is leveled for all parties
and will discourage the altering of
court records
I understand the opposing argument is
that this would increase the costs of
the Judiciary
ensuring that our family court system is
fair and balanced and there's an equal
playing field for all I think that far
outweighs any discussion regarding
finances
and money so I want to thank you for
your time it's been a real privilege and
honor to be here today thank you
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony
thank you Mr chair
uh for the record my name is Dana
Albrecht you may be familiar with me
from prior testimony uh on other bills
or articles in the union leader I am one
of the parties who has been adversely
affected very strongly by the issues
raised here and so I would like to speak
in strong support of sections two and
three of this bill
uh time permitting at the discretion of
the committee I can chair I can cycle
back to thoughts on one your call on
that
um please be brief
yes uh two reasons uh
number one this provides strong
accountability to the New Hampshire
judicial branch and number two this
helps alleviate costs to the parties
concerning accountability in my own case
we have a case spanning over two years
of judicial misconduct where we have
three radically different versions of
what's supposed to be an official
um
that hearing uh the handouts are sort of
evidence and support they're not my
testimony that hearing took place on
November 6th 2020 before Master Del pra
uh I immediately ordered a transcript
and I got it fairly quickly
what I didn't know is that uh within a
week escribers wrote an email to the
administrative office of the courts
concerning inappropriate comments of the
judicial officer
uh notably who gives an f and calling my
children a bunch of morons and wrote in
their email to the AOC
quote of course we're not going to
transcribe that
uh the following day chief
administrative Judge David King was
fully aware of this he's got the email
in front of him and he wrote an email to
marital Master uh Dal pra in charge of
the hearing spelling out we've got an
issue with these two comments
uh what he didn't do is do anything to
correct the transcript and what he
didn't do is make clear to The JCC
that uh Master Del Pera had done this
uh all he asked is that Master Del pra
speak to the JCC about it
um
by the time you get to February 16th
you know these are in chronological
order
uh The JCC is actually dismissed that
this is any evidence of wrongdoing why
because they don't have an accurate
transcript of the proceedings why don't
they have an accurate transcript of the
proceedings because judge king made sure
by the time we get to
November 30th you know quite some time
uh I'm up on appeal with this
you know appeals you need a transcript
and the Supreme Court dockets the first
version of the transcript which is the
one I got
when I ordered it
um
just like you would expect
moving forward by the time they read my
brief and you get to December 25th
December 10th the Supreme Court realizes
that there's a problem with this
transcript
so you can see the order in a supreme
court order
in my case where judicial misconduct has
been left out of a transcript
again the administrative judge made sure
it wasn't in there
um
so
by then you get the second version of
this
uh I don't have the final order in here
but I could get it to you the final
order on appeal is I believe December 6
uh and that final order is based off a
um
after they already decided this you get
to March of next year
and the judicial conduct committee
orders a third
version of a disk transcript
the first two versions were only 133
pages long
the third version
is 144 pages long
they kind of left this some stuff out
uh I did not include all 410 pages of
all three versions of these transcripts
I did in this packet include just enough
of covers and last pages so you can kind
of tell them apart and figure out the
differences
and read about the Red Sox and their
friendly Red Sox fans
uh that's only in the third version that
um
so uh escribers pays again this is
covered by The JCC 950 dollars
um moving forward by the time we get to
October
uh I ask that's when I first find out
there's a third version
and I ask escribers for it and they tell
me they're not allowed to give it to me
without the permission of the judicial
branch about one minute to wrap it up
please okay uh
and I think the rest of this speaks for
itself
uh
that sort of the story I think we've
kind of become a spectacle to the world
and to angels and to men and just to
address comments on privacy for rebuttal
um
the bill as written
uh says a party to a case can make a
recording well a party to the face can
get the official recording and release
that as well if they feel like it so
there's really no difference there
um between something they made or the
official in terms of privacy
um if you would like me to speak to
number one I can otherwise I'll take
questions a section one of the bill
otherwise I'll take questions because I
excuse me
Mr Albrecht uh you've read the bill yes
specific to where there were States in
uh line seven that ultimately three
transcripts are generated
plaintiff defendant and the court
however
the last statement says the courts
reviews the differences and then decides
what's appropriate does that not make
and how it's worded
you
uh
why
I forgive me I don't understand the
question if we've got
um well let me now clarify what and I
appreciate your testimony today you're
stating uh well what I understand you're
stating and not previous testimony as
well
and I have the same sensitivity of
honesty in government in the court
system is
the uh who is hitting the button the key
the TA the tag on what is recorded and
then what becomes the
Authority having jurisdictions specific
to the testimony
as written
now there could be three in here there's
again plaintiff defendant right and and
as I as you stated but that last
statement says that that the court The
Authority having jurisdiction within the
am I said determines which recordings
and transcripts are complete and
adequate for use in the Appellate
Procedure doesn't it make the intent
moot that that the intent there could
still allow the judge to kick out what
he or he or she does not want to have in
the public sector uh correct but now you
have two other recordings to dispute
that to cover all of these other cases
you've heard about where people don't
have the benefit like I do of sort of
more proof and evidence that something
was left out okay one follow-up Mr
chairman thank you Mr chairman does that
not then presume that the plaintiff or
defendant within the case
will then appeal to the to the to the
higher court and the expense and the
cost of that could be a be a restriction
on them able to do that
uh sure but if they're going to appeal
they're better off with it than with
that without without it and they could
also send it to the JCC rather than do
an appeal if they feel there's
misconduct
one final one one more one more one
final one
would you agree then what we both just
said that this can continue on is that a
wording here specific that the testimony
as found in the court
between the as in in the court hearing
is specifically only document that will
be then made available to all as
recorded
I think if there's a dispute you have up
to three versions and in most cases
hopefully you don't have a dispute and
everybody's happy with the official one
and you haven't been up to this point
and I haven't been
I don't think I deserve that title but
they call me speaker earlier they're
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman that's good
well it's supposed to be changed um I
think what you where we left off uh is
where I want to pick up on that last
sentence and the point I may have been
missed there was that it's you've now
moved into the applet Court you've got a
different judge on it and that may have
been missed but I also own that same
sentence I'm concerned about the last
phrase there where it's and just read
the whole sentence it says the Appellate
Court shall review the differences in
recordings and Associated transcripts
okay so we're not we're in a different
court now right and determine which
recordings and transcripts are complete
inadequate for use in the Apple
procedure
by using the word complete it makes me
think it you have to choose between one
and the other and it sounds like what
you want to do is be able to let the
athlete judge choose which pieces
they want so I'm concerned about
for completeness
I think you're correct and I suspect you
there might be possible for some
language revisions to better accomplish
the goal here just to make sure if
people feel there are discrepancies that
they can look at
all of the available material maybe you
can help us with that I do not see any
of the sponsors of this bill in the room
so if one has questions of improvement
before this bill is exact which it won't
be today uh just a reminder you may wish
to speak to representative Bernardi or
one of the co-sponsors because they're
not here to note them
foreign
thank you so much for your testimony
you're welcome Mr chairman
may I submit written later on point one
sure thank you
you've heard numbers of people in
support of the bill now the chair
recognizes someone in opposition to the
bill and as we are trying to balance
fairness especially when uh testimonies
we wish to be limited in length the
opposition will get a little bit more
because this person is the opposition
the chair recognizes uh Richard head
please we've met him this morning
foreign
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Richard head I'm the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch
and I appreciate your comment Mr
chairman and I put five minutes on the
card if with obviously your discretion I
may ask for a little more time than that
um
the bill itself
looking at the bill one as I had
mentioned this this morning and as the
judges mentioned this morning there is
no longer a family court family court is
used in the in the language of this bill
there's a Family Division
and Family Division I think it is also
important to recognize and recall what
exactly is in the Family Division
because we're not only talking about uh
divorces and parenting So Family
Division does have divorce obviously in
parenting it involves child support it
involves domestic violence petitions it
involves guardianships of minors uh
termination of parental rights abuse and
neglect actions children in need of
services juvenile delinquency and some
adoptions
this bill is not limited in its scope it
says family court again my assumption it
would be that that really is intended to
refer to family division
I think it's also
um
important to know in in and
um I'm going to start with the
transcript and recording part of this
bill and then talk about the rules part
of the bill it's also important to know
and recognize that there is currently a
rule
um regarding photographing and recording
and broadcasting that already exists in
our in our court and in our family
division in rule 1.29 says that accept
as otherwise provided by this rule or
other provisions of law in the long
world I'm not going to read the whole
thing
um any person whether or not a member of
an established media organization shall
be permitted to photograph record and
broadcast all Court proceedings that are
open to the public
provided that such person provides
advance notice to the court in
accordance with the rule that he or she
intends to do so there is a mechanism
currently in place with the judge's
permission to record in a courtroom and
that's important because the judge is
going to recognize who are the parties
who's going to be testifying what are
the issues and
um
is it one legally confidential so it
cannot be broadcast and and the intent
of this bill I get is uh to provide a a
copy of a record
but
if as this bill is written there is no
discretion on the part of the judge and
everybody has a right to record
everything in Family Division we are
talking about a a tremendous breadth of
cases and also a tremendous risk because
notwithstanding the goal of it being
created as an alternate record it can be
also be used uh in an abusive way and it
can be used because these things can be
immediately posted on the internet they
can be modified if somebody wants to
post it on the internet and they're not
things that are in our control so we
don't have any control over these over
these recordings so they are property of
the person who recorded it the other
aspect of it is that if somebody is
recording and the judge doesn't know and
the judge cannot say hey by the way
somebody in the audience may be
recording this it may capture
conversations going on around that
person and they're unaware necessarily
that there's a recording going on um
there are tremendous risks associated
with simply allowing a recording and in
fact mandating the right to have a
recording in this in this wide range of
of proceedings
um
the other aspect of it is that this as
as was pointed out the bill would say
that the Appellate judges which is our
Supreme Court we don't have an
intermediate
appellate court that for the vast
majorities there are some instances
where you peel the superior court but
primarily what we're talking about is an
appeal to the Supreme Court and as I
read this it would say that the
Appellate Court shall review the
differences so the judges sort of huddle
start listening to days and days of test
of recordings and try to figure it out
and the reality is the judges don't
determine what is the record the Supreme
Court judges for example the re the
transcript is created by a transcription
agency that's certified they have
certain guidelines and and requirements
in the in the process they use to make a
transcript of the official proceeding if
something is said off the Record and it
is captured on the audio that does not
become a part of the official record
it's not a part of the proceeding and
they have they have you know various
rules and standards that they apply and
escribers is is the current creator of
the official transcript that is sent to
the Supreme Court it's not done by Court
Personnel it's not done
by the Supreme Court Justices
and that recorded or that transcript is
then provided to the court as the
official transcript
if somebody
says the official transcript is an error
and here's the error and this is what we
think happened and this does happen they
file something with the Supreme Court so
everything this transcript is missing
something
the Supreme Court Justices do not then
sort of gather up and decide what it is
what what is an official transcript they
send it back to escribers and say this
was this was raised tell us what the
official record says and it comes back
and and sometimes it's a spelling
correction sometimes it's a word it
depends on what it is
um but the official transcript is
created by escribers
um in addition this this bill does not
have any standards for the transcript
that would be created by this third
party is it
created by an official trans
or a certified transcriptionist is it
something that is a transcript created
by a party writing really fast and
saying this is the transcript I created
it doesn't have any sort of Standards
associated with it which is the the sort
of Need for having a a certified
official record
um
so we do in terms of of the recording
you know there is a process by which a
party or anyone can ask for to make a
recording during the course of a of a
public proceeding
it just simply has to be done with the
presiding judge's permission because the
presiding judge needs to be able to
control the courtroom another example
would be we have somebody who's in these
are very personal matters and if if in
the course of testimony it becomes
apparent that just the fact that that
some number of people are recording this
Um this can affect the way in which
people are testifying and that can have
you know simply that that fact can have
an impact on some incredibly personal
testimony uh and and we do have a
concern that this is going to adversely
affect the way in which people testify
the way in which information is provided
to the judge and ultimately have a very
negative impact on the judicial system
the Integrity of the system and the
ability of a judge to control the
judge's own courtroom
um
with regard to
the judge turning on and turning off the
the the recording machine I did so I've
I've heard this before last year there
was testimony to that effect
specifically in that case it was Judge
intercasso I reached out to the clerk in
Nashua and I said there was testimony
that Judge Andrew Casa was turning the
recording on and off can you just tell
me can she do that from the bench so the
clerk went up to then former judge
intercostal's bench and there is no
switch behind the bench and I also
um last week when I when I was talking
with judge Garner about him coming this
morning I asked him can you turn that
recording on and off
and the clerk in Nashua and judge
garnerable said no they don't have
controls at the bench you have to get up
you have to get off the bench you have
to go down to where the clerk would
normally sit and manually turn it on and
off so there's like physically you have
to get up and go down and turn it on and
off there is and and the clerk and ashwa
uh said there is a mute button behind
the bench okay so she's very thorough
Ransom tests and what the mute button
does is when people are coming up for a
bench conference she can hit mute the
judge can hit mute and it doesn't go
over the speakers in the courtroom so he
can have a private conversation at the
bench that's not broadcast in the
courtroom but the recording continues to
run the mute button did not and she
tested it did not does not impact the
recording itself so I was unable at
least in those instances where I
specifically asked for a check on it
they could not recreate that in any way
shape or form and judge Garner said
there is simply in his experience no way
of doing it we do not in Circuit Court
which is Family Division have court
monitors a clerk will sometimes be
responsible or a bailiff and you heard
that
the judge will ask the bailiff if nobody
else in the courtroom because we don't
use Court monitors there anymore
to turn it on and not turn off but again
has to announce bailiff can you please
turn that off
um
I'm there's some other stuff but I'm in
the interest of time I'm going to turn
over to the issue of court rules and
just briefly address the issue of court
rules
um
there were a couple things I just want
to clarify rule 1.2 as was said talks
about waiver of rules doesn't just
simply say a judge can waive any and all
rules and by the way there is in the
executive branch side a rule about rules
jail Carr has all the rules about what
rules are and jailcar has a very
specific rule that says if there is
going to be authority to waive any rule
there has to be a rule that says you can
waive rules you don't have a rule that
says you can waive rules you simply
can't do it every administrative rule
you you look at there'll be a provision
maybe not up top the way we do it we put
it right at the top
executive branch rules all have a waiver
provision it's a part of rule making we
put ours at the very top but it does not
simply say the judge can waive any and
all rules it says a rule can be waived
for if good cause appears and Justice
may require it that's the sort of
standard language you will see in a
rules waiver provision
with regard to The Rules of Evidence it
does not say a judge can waive the rules
of evidence rule 2.2 says that the rules
of evidence do not apply and this is
again this is Family Division Rule and
if you think about it it's an important
part of Family Division because the vast
vast majority of people appearing in
Family Division are pro se they're not
represented by Council I took a lot of
evidence in law school I've practiced
law for 30 plus years I know the rules
of evidence if you have not shown up in
court The Rules of Evidence will trap
you they will trap the unwary you you
know that is
a way in which a a party who's not
deeply
familiar with the Rules of Evidence can
get stuck and trapped
so we do have a rule that says the Rules
of Evidence don't apply but the court
May utilize the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence to enhance the predictable
orderly fair and reliable presentation
of evidence so for example there is and
people generally get this the evidence
that's being presented has to be
relevant so yes the judges May shut
somebody down and say you're not talking
about the issue that is before us today
you're talking about something that's
very important to you may be deeply
important to you but today I'm trying to
resolve this issue and so I won't allow
that evidence it has to be relevant so
that is a rule of evidence that's the
type of orderly necessary implementation
of the rules that a judge is going to
apply in order to ensure that they fit
within the 30 minutes because as you
heard judge Garner this morning there
are going to be another 20 people behind
you who also need to come up and have
their hearings
um so there needs to be some level of
control and again it gets to that issue
of a judge being able to control their
own courtroom in their own docket
um
the other aspect of the rules is you
have if you don't know what the rules
are to do a blanket waiver without any
discretion on the judge so judge under
this under this bill would have no
discretion to waive a rule that simply
says thou shall not waive any rules we
have as was said a number of rules and
if you're not
deeply familiar with all of them and if
you haven't looked at all the unintended
consequences are are significant so for
example we have a rule that says you
have to appear within 15 days if you
can't waive that sometimes there are
very legitimate reasons why somebody is
going to be late on an appearance we
can't waive that rule 15 days Days 16 in
the morning they come in they say
whatever their their excuse was to valid
excuse we can't waive the rules
legislature says we cannot waive rules
your appearance cannot come in
okay now what that person doesn't have
an appearance in the court they can't
participate
um it is we have a rule that says when
addressing a witness or the court you
should stand
um okay we can't waive that rule
there are people who are not going to be
able to stand
I also don't fully understand the
statutory or I'm sorry the bill in the
sense of the rules because a lot of the
times the rule says you know X is the
rule unless otherwise Allowed by the
judge is that a waiver under this bill
or is that not a waiver under the bill
they may not be a waiver under the bill
because it's part of the rule itself but
a lot of the rules say that so it
becomes very unclear at least in my mind
as to as to truly what the intent is of
um
so I think the the inability of
a blanket prohibition on the court to
way to to not be able to waive rules of
prohibition and waiving rules has the
opportunity and can create tremendous
barriers to Justice create tremendous
barriers to fairness
um and has just a host of unintended
consequences I think what you have is
judges who are trying to apply a very
complex statutory scheme in all of these
areas
um that I that I went through with it
which is within the context of Family
Division
um and it is ultimately the judge's dis
the need for the judge to be able to
take into account all of the facts and
circumstances when applying the rules
and applying the the uh right of of
anyone not just parties to record within
the courthouse or within a courtroom
um and to create a
unwavable situation an unwaverable
process is going to have significant
negative consequences on ultimately the
the ability of the courts uh to perform
its job and form its its duties
and Mr chairman if I can just have one
second to take a look at my notes from
the comments uh just just make sure
I'm not missing too much I know I'm
missing something
um
probably not
key but so I'll be happy to stop there
and answer any questions thank you for
your presentation I'm looking at the
history of of this bill as it's loped
its way through this committee and also
Judiciary
um and it was a bill that didn't make it
but it sounds to me like portions of it
somehow did make it it has to do with
parties recording in court proceedings
having notified the courts and other
parties they will be recording I think
you mentioned that's on the books if I'm
not mistaken it's not a statue it's a
Court rule it's a Court rule it applies
to each each Court a Family Division has
that rule so in Family Division it is
thank you any questions
I've got a bucket of them representative
thank you Mr chairman all the letters
thank you for testifying
um
this afternoon uh and
your extensive research I appreciate
that
I have one question about a
a situation that was brought up
concerning
children who testify
in the fact that their comments and so
forth should be
either redacted from written transcript
or removed from verbal
can you speak a little bit about that
truthfully I thank you thank you for the
question I would I need to ask some
questions to make sure I'm accurate as
to uh as to exactly
how that how that applies in the
transcript there are and what the what
the precautions have to be and I'm happy
to follow up I don't know the answer I'd
be reluctant to say the answer without
confirming you can follow up yeah thank
I jotted down here the judge has control
of the courtroom
um I can understand presiding over a
room where you really kind of do want to
have control of it but what if the judge
is the problem we've heard some stories
um
not most of
judges but it seems like more than one
so they're
um when I think the judges so far
referenced are no longer judges
um that's not a coincidence and there
have been judicial conduct committee
proceedings involving those judges I
know that so
um in
at the requester Mr Albrecht I've
listened to for example many of the
recordings that that relate to
his case
um with master delpra
[Music]
um
the
my interpretation and I will caveat it
with that is that the comments of Master
dalpra so these this was also during an
era when
um
things were being done remotely so I
believe the my memory is that the
recordings that we're talking about were
all remote so the parties were not all
in the courtroom at the time and that
these were comments
um inappropriate comments made by Master
delpra
[Music]
um
not quote unquote on the record not to
all the parties they were essentially
comments he was making to himself and to
whoever was like his his clerk in his
Chambers or in the courtroom but not as
part of the proceeding
um one of them was it and I won't get
into the specifics but I think that's
why it did not make the transcript in
the first instance because I believe the
transcriptionist interpreted that to me
and it was not a part of the record
um and what happened in terms of the
transcript after that truth I'm not I'm
not positive but those are comments that
are in the recordings
um and you can find I was unable to find
and I actually don't know why
um but I was unable to find the can of
worms comment that
um
that Ms Gerard had mentioned
um and I know that the judicial conduct
committee did hear it because they said
that in their in their findings I simply
was unable to find it but it obviously
existed because the uh the judicial
conduct committee did
um report that they listened to it but
beyond that I honestly don't know where
that re where that came from or the
context of it could I infer then from
this testimony that
um if different citizens heard a
series of inappropriate comments in open
court
there is an appeal process there is a
complaint
place where people can go and that place
is that takes these seriously I I think
there are two things uh one is the
judicial conduct committee obviously if
there's misbehavior by a judge that is
the appropriate if it's in open court
and it raises questions about the
impartiality or the ability of the judge
to oversee the case there could be
emotion in that case asking the judge to
recuse him or herself
um I
so you know there are processes
um
and if somebody believes that the
transcript is missing something and they
have some evidence of that it can be
brought forward and and somebody would
have to listen to the recording but it
is ultimately based on the official
recording and the official transcript uh
and those are the things that
um we have control over and that we
ultimately uh
knows is the official record one other
comment we are upgrading our recording
system it became evident during the
course of the pandemic when we were
doing remote testimony that our currents
are our existing system was unable to
record each party who's coming in on one
system separately so when people were
speaking over each other in our old
system they would overlap in the
recording also the new system uh primary
reason we went out and got it was so
that we could Now record each person as
a separate Channel and the
transcriptionist can then take the turn
take the testimony of each individual
who's testifying now that we're relying
much more on on remote technology that
became apparent during the course of the
pandemic that that was a need for an
upgrade
you may know from the media that I chair
a working group on the dealing with
medical malpractice claims and their
reportage to the public and this is a
would you believe I understand how
finely nuanced all of this has to be
it's a difficult job thank you I uh I
agree
other questions yes representative
Nelson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
uh taking my question
um regarding waivers is there any um are
there any record and database of uh the
actual waivers that judges
um
do for lack of better term
um so if there was a problem
it could be easily recognizable
showing a pattern if
so thank you for the question the answer
is the short answer is no
um so this the bill you have before you
today there were two parts it was two
bills last session
um the
um
transcript part of it came out of
committee uh unanimous itl the recording
I'm sorry the waiver part of it came out
of it as a new bill which was to create
a database
um the the problem obviously with any
database is it requires input so during
the course of a
two-day trial three-day trial judges
constantly making decisions is
constantly uh
possibly you know there's a rule that
has to be waived judge may not even sort
of formally recognize oh I'm I'm waving
rule you know 8.2 Part B whatever it's
just they know the rule they know what
the situation is and they're allowing
something to come in where they're
allowing something to happen we would
have to have either continuous
monitoring of every judge all the time
or
um we just simply don't have a mechanism
for inputting all of this type of data
that's happening in real time in every
courthouse in every courtroom both
verbally and in writing so unfortunately
and I appreciate the the desire for it
and the interest in it it is uh it would
be a remarkably complicated undertaking
uh to be able to do and do well and do
accurately
um and would require
a fair amount of resources
representative Bickford
thank you Mr chairman
um how long was uh
was it judge delper or marital Master
Del pero or bull uh Master Del Master
deltro he's a marital Master okay you
don't have marital Masters anymore right
the last marital Master retired last
year
yeah that's the end of that that's the
end of that
um but my how long was uh Metal Master
dumpra on the bench um is this to the
point of the bill this is getting a
little close to uh disciplinary matters
that perhaps maybe beyond our scope I
was kind of following up what you were
you reckon you were going in oh no oh no
no practice
there is no good answer I can give to
that
continue for the time being just be
careful do you know how long a master
Delbert was on the bench I don't know
exactly it was a he was he had a long
tenure uh as a master but 20 years comes
to mind but I don't know the answer
that's fine thank you
under rule 1.2 waiver of rules it begins
as good cause appears and his Justice
may require the Family Division May
waive the application of any rule on
face value that sounds wonderful it begs
the question according to whom who makes
the decision that that judge May waive
that rule
these are all decisions that are being
made by the presiding judge so the
presiding judge is the determining
factor and good cause and Justice in
this case he waives the rules he or she
chooses to
uh that's correct the the as with any
any case you know the interpretation of
the rules the waiver of the rules and
the in the same with the statute is done
by the presiding judge based upon the
facts evidence information before that
judge
um and that judges is making it making
the decisions we don't have a process of
uh waiver committee waiver judge it's
it's the judge Who's involved at the
time and they could be happening in real
time in the courtroom as information is
being presented
without mentioning names or specifics
um but more than as a hypothetical
have there been instances where a judge
has so
missed
the idea of good cause or Justice in the
waving of rules and done it repeatedly
we've all had bad days
that uh con some judicial conduct is
taken against him or her I don't know
the answer to that okay
I would not research that specifically
would that be something that you sense
your profession would do
I apologize can you repeat the question
I just didn't understand do you
would it be would it be likely never to
happen that the judicial review I missed
the exact conduct command would ever
have a situation where judge X has been
brought before them because there have
been too many complaints that too many
rules have been waived and they just do
not seem to be for good cause or or as
Justice may require in other words this
person this judge is misusing the waiver
of rules and there is a mechanism where
that may be dealt with by one's peers
yeah so you know I don't know it's it's
you know
parties
use the rules in various ways so when a
judge waives a rule it may very well
upset the other party because that other
party may have seen a great Advantage by
virtue of the person not filing an
appearance on day 15.
um so you know the the
reaction to a waiver of rule can be one
of two things one is
I really really wanted that rule to be
applied as it's written because that was
to my uh
advantage in litigation I've litigated
for over 30 years uh I liked it when the
rules Favored Me and when those were
waived I recognized that that was
disappointing for me that's one aspect
of it the other aspect is as you suggest
which is there are occasions if a judge
is waiving a rule because that judge is
biased and wants a particular party to
be successful
that and and and a a party an attorney
anybody believes that to be true the
complaint can be filed with the judicial
conduct committee my my answer was
simply I've never looked through all of
the judicial conduct committee
complaints to see sort of whether or not
these are triggered or whether this is a
source of of complaint my interest is
twofold the bill at hand and the
parallel track that I'm running in terms
of malpractice so I'm interested to see
fair enough how you doing
seeing none thank you so much thank you
Mr chairman and now we have one final
pink card I will accept no more where
over time so
representative for Salem for how many
years six six
and now in vacationing how was your trip
which one the one we didn't take because
that was it
oh bummer yeah oh I'll go in April okay
um
we've all Heard lots of things oh I'm
supposed to say your name I kind of
introduced this is Betty gay from Salem
and six years House Bill 218 with
financial evaluation
uh actually contains three former bills
so I'm going to pass around with passing
around the price of a transcript I had
to call
escribers because they only tell you the
price per page you have no idea how many
pages it takes but in talking it's not
in writing but in talking I found out
they estimate 50 pages per hour
okay
the first price is seven dollars a page
so for one hour it's 350 dollars so it's
not expensive to get the uh the
recordings I didn't even write it down
it's 25 or 35 and you pay that and then
if you want a CD pay another 25.
so that's that's not bad it's the
transcripts that cut people out who are
not filthy rich or make people who have
really great credit run up a hundred
thousand dollars there are people here
in this room who have spent more like
three hundred thousand
and a friend of mine who couldn't come
she became a friend because I was
working on this
and she contacted me
you very wisely pointed out that this
needs another paragraph that points out
what you can use the recordings for it's
just for appellate purposes
because
um
so she suggested
the judge let's see no the two points
here she wants to you know make sure
that you understand that judge
definitely can turn the recording off
and on because it happened to her you
can watch it happen
and when she got her recording of course
parties let's see where is it that the
children she said my daughters want to
make sure
that uh a personal recording made in
court would not be able to be publicized
so she said I would like it that parties
may only use the recording for court
matters and cannot distribute them in
any way paper or electronically and if
they do some penalty would be assessed
in no manner May the transcript be used
other than within the judicial system in
its entirety I say this because I know
my children her two teenage daughters
would not want what happened to them
out in public or be cherry-picked by
parties and used out of context on
social media
I was really sad she couldn't come but
the duties of being a single mother are
challenging I'm going to reach you seven
points you've already heard so much
hopefully these will all strike a point
into your memory
okay the first one was that we really
need an amendment that points out what
you'd use this recording for
two children ordinarily do not get to
testify they have no right to testify
unless the judge permits it that is a
solid rule among these
e-scribers prices which is uh you know
on the Green Sheet I have the escribers
prices and then another company
um the point is
if that's if the accuracy you know I'm
sure you pay a premium when you have a
chain of command
but the important thing is does the
we just discovered she discovered that
the East Driver Services their prices
it won't take long
or transcript differences to be
recognized
the Appellate the the Appellate Court
for family court in New Hampshire is the
Supreme Court
you don't get to re-hear your case
uh that's another bill I'd like to see
past it used to be that you could go to
Superior Court and re-hear your case now
the Supreme Court just evaluates whether
the court followed the right procedures
you can't plead the you know I didn't
get a chance I was denied an evidentiary
hearing I have two friends that I know
were denied evidence
they didn't have to give it to him so
they didn't and one judge even said I've
already made up my mind I don't need
evidence
it is no surprise that the courts object
to every effort to reform
their people like all of us we don't
like to be have our errors pointed out
and nobody likes change either unless
they're the ones controlling it so I'm
not surprised that Mr head comes once
more to every single one of my bills to
tell why it would be terrible
but the point is we have such errors
going on in court the only way I had to
laugh when he said well you just show
evidence that this was done how do you
show evidence that a recording is
inadequate if you don't have a recording
to prove it
we have lots of incidences of people
saying the judge said so and so and so
and so I paid my 30 25 35 bucks
it's not in there
and you can't appeal
you can't appeal it if you don't have
evidence
I heard judge Foley's name mentioned
earlier so I'm going to say it again
representative we put just about
everybody except the maternity head
because he was the only one speaking on
the other side but I'm I'm going to ask
you to speed up okay thank you well a
friend of mine who you all know who's
very famous and I didn't ask her for
permission to call her so I will not
quote her name
she asked prospective judges she asked
current judges
and one judge said about Foley oh he
says everybody knows if he has the
choice to give custody
to of children to a mother who's been
very good and a father who just spent
the last 10 years in prison he's going
to give the kids to the the father who
just got out of prison
I'm really upset that if judges know
this know the Prejudice why isn't the
JCC responding we have lots of
experience with people appealing to The
JCC and having the response no finding
so please help us you can fix the bill
you can fix fine-tune the wording just
realize how serious this is and how this
impacts people's lives to have no
alternative and not to be rich not you
know it you just can't pursue under the
current rules unless you've got Deep
Pockets so let's make it more fair
any questions for The Honorable Betty
gay
seeing none thank you so much
um that closes the hearing on House Bill
218 couple things before you leave
please
um
represent uh for retired representative
gay and representative Stapleton if uh
since the prime sponsor was not here uh
it is ultimately his choice he can
in two weeks we can exec the bill as it
stands or it is the choice that based on
what was heard today
he may wish to have an amendment that's
true with all of these bills point of
order what I I thought you guys were the
only ones who could submit an amendment
we can receive it from someone else and
put our name on it
okay so it can become our Amendment it
is our Amendment but somebody else can
write it for us and we turn it in
um I want to give a little peekaboo at
what we may be doing next week
I hope to have an exec session on House
Bill 34 raising the marriage age to 18
House Bill 200 choice of a counselor the
first one was representative Levesque
the second one is representative Nutter
Upham
um we will also hear House Bill 471 from
representative yokola late of this
committee on Final disposition in a
divorce we will hear House Bill 438 a
support person at Family Court
proceedings which I take points on and
representative long will be in the chair
next week
you coming
me too yeah well sorry
um in the afternoon House Bill 497
representative Hull confidentiality with
dcyf things
representative Hall also with Bill 535
attorney appointed for a child we may or
may not
hear House Bill 120 this is on the
sununu center's closing funding for a
new place all of that sort of thing we
are trying to do this in tandem with the
Senate they may be having an amendment
to the bill that is already in the
Senate and very similar in the house
and we'll find that out and they will
have their Senate meeting and do
whatever they're going to do and then we
have to be ready to jump right away here
to get it out of here to finance to the
house floor and on its happy little way
to the governor we hope in about six
weeks so you may hear something about
House Bill 120 next week or not and
there may be amendments so watch The
Press if you hear the Senate's got an
amendment that they have adopted then
that puts us out of sync we have a
committee of conference we don't want to
do that so just watch the media for that
final item
I did what what I always did when I was
teaching graduate school and that's if
I'm going to teach a course for the
first time I ask colleagues what's the
best book on the subject so I asked
around and the best interests of the
child is considered a wonderful book and
come to find out representative long has
known this book for some time
and maybe some of you do I bought three
copies of it so I wouldn't have to pay
postage you know I'd get three and I
mean I'm cheap with other people's money
too and so I have two of them for sale
at my cost here so first one who has
21.99 if you come up to me with 22
dollars I have two books and I have two
pennies for change
seeing nothing thank you we are done for